Shannon,
it's been a while.
[inaudible] live.
We're live.
Do you wanna talk about that or no?
Shane thing.
Did you have something to say?
Everyone's,
I mean the clip and uh,
and I think you said something about taking a knee in the middle of a gunfight.
And he said,
yeah,
that was bad.
And he's a fucking savage.
What did you do?
What happened?
Refresh.
My memory were in Afghanistan,
right.
And the guys,
I'm with the Afghan soldiers on with gang bushed by the Taliban and I just went
down on one knee and carried on talking.
Ah,
um,
and chain said,
yeah,
he's fucking so apparently that's a compliment.
I wasn't sure who were,
journalists are very fascinating people to me because,
uh,
oftentimes you guys move towards the gunfire with the camera to get the shot.
And you know,
I've talked to folks before who have worked as a,
a war journalist and they say,
you almost don't think you're,
you,
you're,
you're so concentrated on getting the shot.
You don't think about the fact that you might get shot.
It's a safety mechanism.
Yeah.
You think you're protected by looking at it on a screen rather than realizing
it's,
it's actually happening in real life right now.
That is stupid.
It's so strange.
There was that.
Try to keep this.
So I got like a fist from your face and perfect.
There we go.
I was with them,
the US marines for operation most direct,
like the biggest operation of the Afghan war.
Um,
and that was a town called margin that was controlled by the Taliban.
And I met up with this one group of marines.
I used to love going out of the marines because had,
if you were willing to run the same risks are then they'd let you film
everything.
Um,
and their mission was to get dropped by a helicopter in the middle of this town
at 3:00 AM on day one,
and then just fight their way out from the middle of the town.
And as soon as the sun came up,
all of the speakers on the mosques were saying the infidelity here,
the infidels are here,
get your weapons,
get your weapons.
And General Mcchrystal,
I didn't use this rule of courageous restraint saying,
you're not allowed to shoot unless your shutter or unless you see someone
preparing a hostile act.
And the Taliban had figured out how to use this.
So I'm sitting in this field with about 28 marines watching the Taliban drop
off,
guys in buildings all around us with their weapons wrapped in blankets knowing
the marines can't shoot them.
So they're setting up the perfect ambush.
Um,
and as soon as we started walking across the field,
it started and it's like nothing I've ever heard or experienced before.
We ran and dived into a ditch.
The guys either side of me got,
got hit,
one of them badly.
The guy was killed on the other side of the field,
almost straight away.
Um,
I was there alone filming it and myself and because I was watching the whole
thing through this tiny little screen on my camera,
it felt like I wasn't,
you know,
in,
in as much dangerous as they were.
And I was so afraid and the adrenaline runs out after a while and you just
become numb and you,
I mean,
then I'd resigned myself.
I thought we all going to get killed.
We were completely surrounded in that number now RPGs and snipers.
Um,
and I watched it back and the footage is pretty good,
you know,
like changing shirts,
I'm zooming in and focusing on,
I think focusing on that helped me,
helped me,
you know.
How did you get out of it?
I mean,
to this day,
I'm not even sure.
I think the marines just started identifying Taliban targets and picking them
off.
And then the Taliban ran out of ammunition and the actual ambush lasted like
six,
seven hours of nonstop fighting.
Yeah.
And then we ran into an old building,
which is,
which became their base for six months,
just in an abandoned building.
And they shelled that all night.
And the fight and carried on the whole next day.
But,
but that first day in the ditch,
I remember saying to myself,
you're an idiot.
You never say no to anything.
You always just,
you know,
join up and sign up for these insane trips.
And if you survive today and you're probably not going to survive if you do
survive today,
don't ever go out with these idiots ever again.
Um,
and the next day they said,
oh,
we're going to launch this operation,
take this mosque.
And I went out with them all over again.
It's felt like a good night's sleep.
Yeah.
When he was even a good night's sleep.
But yeah.
But yeah,
once you survive,
a few of you,
I mean,
I remember when I started doing this,
you had an idea of what,
what good odds and bad we'll odds were and that you know,
you're willing to accept lesser and lesser odds as time goes on because nothing
happens in it's,
it's easy to get,
to get careless and stupid.
Great.
That's a real thing with violence,
right.
Until you've actually experienced it firsthand,
personally being enacted on yourself,
it almost doesn't seem real even when bullets that sipping bio head.
Yeah.
Is that a just a weird compartmentalization thing that people are capable of?
Is that what it is?
I think it is.
I mean,
I think with me it's slightly different.
Um,
I mean I,
I took part in this Mtma therapy for PTSD recently and one of the,
one of the revelations that came out as a result of that was I,
I got into this 20 years ago thinking I could help people in Syria,
Palestine,
Congo,
wherever,
by raising awareness about about what's happening after a while you lose faith
in the idea.
So then you start feeling a bit guilty and thinking,
am I just here for my own benefit?
Am I just here to profit in some way and not actually helping whatsoever?
Um,
so I think that guilt made me think you're not important enough to have
something as dramatic as getting shot or blown up.
It happened to you through,
I know that sounds so stupid and never thought that until,
you know,
it came out as part of this therapy,
but I think I really had started thinking that.
So the,
the MTMA therapy made you sort of look at your rational perspective.
Like what,
what,
how are you rationalizing your,
your time in these very,
very dangerous places in,
in ways that I hadn't even thought about.
It was going on in your subconscious.
It was sort of absolute.
Yeah.
You're sort of making these agreements and arrangements in order to be able to
still do that.
Yeah.
And if,
if it continued then it was going to end bad coffee.
Thank you.
Like you know,
there was,
there was only one way it was going to end and I hadn't,
I hadn't seen that coming at all.
I hadn't,
hadn't connected the dots like that at all.
How did you wind up stopping?
Cheers.
I mean this is the biggest,
I haven't stopped and I don't think I'm going to stop.
I,
I did the EMDR therapy thinking this would give me an excuse to stop.
Right.
I thought that's what I wanted.
Three quarters of the way through the first session I was planning the next two
programming.
I mean,
people say you're an adrenaline junkie.
That's not true at all.
It's not a thrill to be there.
It's horrible to be there as an endurance test every single time.
But I still think it's,
it's important.
Do you think it's important because the information that you can get to people,
there's no other way they can get it.
Yeah.
I mean I wonder what impact that has these days.
Um,
but you hope that it doesn't impact or everything has an impact.
I'm sure it has an impact,
but I mean,
the example I was using this,
you know,
some of my colleagues have been broken by this is,
is,
you know,
the Syrian war has been very well covered.
Every crime has been very well documented,
you know,
often with video footage of exactly the crime being carried out.
Has it made any difference whatsoever?
I'm not sure.
The Syrian one is one where you hear,
you hear rational people say that like Assad is not our enemy and that well,
how do you,
what do you feel about that?
I mean I think we're dealing with the legacy of the Iraq and Afghanistan wars in
that even if you want to help,
what's the point?
You can't,
you're only going to make it worse.
I think a lot of people feel that when,
I think that leads some people to think Assad is not a good guy.
He probably does have the blood of hundreds of thousands on his hands,
but we should deal with them anyway because that's better than Iraq or
Afghanistan.
This is because when we do get rid of a leader like Libya with Kaddafi or Iraq
rack with Hussein,
that what happens is you get this power vacuum and then it becomes far worse.
We've tried every model.
We've tried invading Afghanistan,
taking you over,
trying to rebuild the entire culture and armed forces and government ourselves
that has failed miserably.
Tried Iraq,
Libya,
tried leading from the back.
Um,
you know,
limited intervention,
hoping that the guys on the ground could do the fighting for us.
And then Syria,
we've tried almost no intervention whatsoever.
Um,
and all three have failed.
So I think now you've got people,
I mean,
the thing I always think most people would say we should have intervened in
Rwanda.
I think almost everyone would say,
I mean,
Bill Clinton would say that's his biggest regret.
I think in his presence,
he,
most people would say,
we should have intervened in Rwanda.
I think if her window happened tomorrow,
you'd have a lot of people here saying,
it's not worth it.
We won't help.
We can't make the situation better.
So why even try?
Well,
it's so hard when you look at the rest of the world and you see these horrific
conditions and you see warlords and power and you see atrocities being
committed,
and we're sitting over here and you know,
in the valley watching it on Internet and drinking Starbucks,
you know,
oh,
it's just Trump gossip.
Yeah.
I mean,
more so American American foreign coverage was never,
was never great.
No.
Now it's almost gone.
I mean Yemen W we'll see.
I mean because of the [inaudible] Shoji murder may be,
maybe something can happen with Yemen
cause and there is a lot we can do there because we are,
you know,
directly supporting one side.
It almost seems like what you were talking about in a far lesser extent,
the,
the feeling that you get when you're in these war zones,
it's almost like it's not real that you're,
you're covering it through this lens so you're immune from it.
It almost feels like we view the massive conflicts of the world that way.
That like we're watching it on television,
we're seeing it on our phones or our laptops.
It's not,
it's real.
I know it's real.
It is.
It's a real issue.
But it's not real like in terms of it's not knocking on my door.
Yeah.
No,
it's almost like we feel about it that way.
Yeah.
And the numbers as well.
I mean,
you know,
in Syria it could be 800,000 dead,
um,
that people already think what,
what that means.
What does 800,000 dead actually mean?
Right.
Did they,
when I think with certain numbers,
you,
you just,
they just become a,
it just becomes digits and it just doesn't make sense.
Yeah.
It doesn't,
uh,
you like if you hear five guys get killed in a shootout,
you go,
ah,
there's five guys are dead.
Yeah.
You start thinking about it,
you hear 500,000 people died on the other side of the planet.
It's almost,
it almost doesn't register.
Yeah.
But for you it registers.
And you know what I mean,
the reason I started doing this,
you know,
when I was a kid,
as soon as I started reading about these situations and,
and you know,
when I,
I remember reading that in my government,
the British government was arming,
you know,
often the wrong side in these conflicts.
I remember thinking,
how is this not front page news,
right?
How everyone not talking about this every single day.
And I still feel like that now even though I'm clearly out of step with,
you know,
most of the population,
but well,
you were so immersed.
Is it hard for you when you come back and you see the Trump gossip and all the
nonsense and all the things that we engage in on a daily basis here in America
that are really trivial at best.
I mean,
you know,
is it hard for you to,
I mean,
you mean you,
you get to see the worst shit happening in the world all the time.
Is it hard for you to relate?
Yeah.
And then you,
you,
you know,
I mean,
one of the,
one of the main symptoms I had of,
of the PTSD from covering this for so long was,
was it was numbness to physical danger when I was there,
but it was numbness when I got back home.
So you'd come back and you know,
at one point you used to think,
if I come back with,
with the footage I have of whatever conflict,
it's going to have some kind of impact.
It's going to create some kind of ripple and then you come back and you think
that's going to be,
there's gonna be nothing.
The film's going to go out as a few people are going to tweet.
A few people are gonna,
you know,
send me a message.
That's it.
Are we in a information overload state?
I mean you,
you,
if you go back to the early days of the Internet,
Facebook,
it was going to be the free flow of information.
You know,
no borders.
It's,
I mean,
I don't think we,
you can doubt it's made us dumber now that the infant,
there's,
there's so much.
It is not just how much there is,
it's also how much bad stuff yeah.
Gets traction and how much really important stuff doesn't get traction.
I mean,
one of the great things about,
about the Trump era is some of the best writing,
you know,
I think for for years,
but how many people are reading it,
right?
Yeah.
I would like to know how many people read Matt Taibbi is articles.
From the beginning to the end.
Yeah.
I really would like to see them that when you think about the amount of time
that guy puts into an article.
Yeah.
It's such a strange time because it doesn't,
it doesn't seem like any other time.
It doesn't seem like any other time in terms of our consumption of information
or how much information we consume me.
And it's like the,
the,
the sheer volume of it is,
it's almost,
it's almost a insurmountable,
like the sheer volume of data that comes in everyday.
It doesn't go away.
It just,
new data comes in,
it just keeps coming in and piling up.
You know,
it's like porn,
right?
Like you never could watch all the porns yeah,
it does.
It's not possible like,
but they keep making them.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
And like,
ah,
you open up porn hub and you go,
what the f how many of them,
how many of them are there?
Yeah.
And that's,
you know,
that is really data.
I mean,
but then all these crazy internet videos and stories and there's just every day
it's something new.
It's constant.
But,
but you'd have thought that would,
that would have led to a situation where some things are indisputable because,
because there is video evidence,
but,
but it's the opposite of the case.
Nothing is verifiable now.
No matter how much evidence exists,
my concern is that that's leading into this trend of deep fakes and this new
audio editing ability that they have to,
they can take your voice and your,
your mouth and put some stuff in there that you never said.
Yeah.
And you know,
it could be news.
I mean,
you could do that.
It could be a sod.
It could be a Obama,
it could be anyone.
It's so strange and it might get debunked in the New York Times the next day.
No one cares how many people are reading that.
Very few even aware of it.
Yeah.
Very few.
Everything that's taken out of context.
No one reads the full context.
Anything that is a,
a small video clip.
No one's going to see the full thing.
And I think that's what what Trump,
his masters.
He doesn't care if he gets taken upon the next day and the New Yorker,
he knows his base aren't reading the New Yorker.
They don't even aware of that article.
Well it doesn't seem to be bothering him either.
He's one of the rare guys I've been paying attention to him a lot over the last
few months.
He doesn't seem to be getting older like a lot of them do.
Like it's the concern that makes them old,
you know,
it's the stress of the job that makes them all,
he seems to be sleeping in late.
I got traveling and I come back and I read the headlines.
You know,
Trump's having a meltdown screaming in the White House and I seen him on TV.
It looks as happy as a pig in shit.
I don't believe any of that shit they write.
I think they write things like that,
I think yells at people.
But I think yelled at people when he was a real estate mogul.
I mean,
I think,
you know,
he wants to get shit done.
He's a billionaire.
He likes progress.
He likes to make money.
He doesn't like in competence yells at people.
I Dunno man.
It's just,
it's,
I feel like we're at this cusp of something very strange happening.
Like we're in the middle of it right now,
but we're at the cusp of something very strange where all would take is one
massive world event,
one Matt,
to,
to completely remap how we view each other and how we view things.
It's very disconcerting
this,
it feels like without that one big world event,
we're not that far away from that right now.
There are parallel universes right now exist on things that you would have
thought everyone can accept as a basic fact.
Like what,
you know,
um,
uh,
I mean,
Syria.
Yeah.
You know,
the white helmets there,
there are some fairly serious people saying the white helmets are,
you know,
some kind of media front for alk hydro on.
There's,
would you explain the White Helmets for people?
So when there's a,
when there's a bombing and a building collapses,
they go in and drag people out and get them medical attention as quick as
possible.
And people think that they're somehow or another involved in it through a front
yeah.
To,
to,
and,
and the,
the footage is faked in order to drum up sympathy for the rebel held areas.
I mean,
that's,
I've,
I've heard,
you know,
serious people say that.
Serious people.
Yeah.
Not,
not,
not loons on Facebook.
I've heard,
you know,
journalists are,
yeah.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah.
I mean,
Seymour Hersh I think has walked it back a little bit since,
but he said that in the early days.
Why do you think he believed it?
I read a really interesting article about him just a few days ago.
Where was it?
Um,
I forget what it was.
It was,
you know,
the expos ava a really good look at,
look at,
look at him.
And I think he's just spent his career believing rightly that the government
lies about all kinds of things.
And that's got me into a point where he thinks,
well,
they always lie no matter what.
So,
and it's happened to a lot of journalists.
So Robert Fisk see more harsh,
um,
Martha Gellhorn.
I mean,
one of my favorite war correspondents of all time,
I reread some of her stuff recently and,
and the first batch of war reporting she did I think is the best war reporting
I've ever read.
Spanish civil war Vietnam.
Um,
and then she spent 25 years writing novels and then later on wrote about,
I believe it was the Yom Kippur War and was denying that massacre had happened
and saying,
you know,
Arabs,
like they always lie.
There was no massacre and we now know there was a massacre or they weren't
massacres,
um,
in the aftermath of these,
of these wars.
Um,
so I don't know what happens.
I mean,
maybe if you just do this for too long,
you just become so cynical that you're open to these things,
but it's,
yeah,
I'm amazed at Seymour Hersh is,
is open to that idea
when the very people that are calling it,
the very people that have boots on the ground and that are in these war zones or
an calling,
these things,
when they become cynical and they become jaded,
that's when it gets really,
really sketchy.
And,
and we rely so heavily on people like it.
Like there's no,
I'm not going over there.
You know,
Jamie's not going over there,
look at them.
You know what I'm saying?
I mean in,
and you wouldn't be able to really get like,
I know people that have gone to Venezuela and they come back and they go,
I don't know what the fuck is going on over there.
I don't know who to believe.
I don't understand it.
If Venezuela is a very strange one and I get messages all the time and um,
you know,
I've had Abby Martin who goes over there and she has one take on it and I have
other people that I've talked to that have a different take on it and I do not
know.
I don't know who to believe.
And I think you'd have to go over there and do [inaudible] spent a lot of time
to try to figure this out and he would have to be the entire focus of your life
to really try to Parse it out.
I think that's true of a lot of conflicts.
I mean,
one of the,
one of the drawbacks of doing what I do is I'm covering seven or eight things at
once.
So I feel like I'm not expert enough.
And even Afghanistan where I've covered,
I've covered that more than any other and,
but,
but Venezuela is an interesting one cause it's,
there's,
there's such a left right divide on that.
And if you support the opposition,
then you find yourself alongside John Bolton and Donald Trump,
which means that a lot of people are,
can automatically attack you.
Right.
Um,
automatically,
even if it's correct.
And I think it's,
you know,
we can say without a doubt the Maduro has destroyed the economy there.
Maduro has,
uh,
imprisoned,
beaten,
killed journalists.
Um,
there is a movement there that do want genuine elections.
but some people will say,
well,
just because George Bush and other area or John Bolton and this era support the
opposition,
therefore the opposition must be illegitimate.
And the information coming out must be,
must be folks.
And I wish people did rely on,
on people who actually went there,
but it doesn't feel like that.
It feels like they rely on the,
you know,
the guy behind the glass desk on the,
on the news when they were allowed opinion,
the people who were actually there,
well we still have this idea in our head that the,
the person who's reading the news is the authority and the Don Lemon has the
inside scoop or whoever it is.
You know,
and I think it used to be that those guys would spend 20 or 30 years traveling
and then they'd get the cushy job behind the glass desk in the studio.
Now it seems like you can go straight to the cushy job behind the glass desk.
Well,
did we just need someone who's relatable,
who can read a teleprompter,
you know,
who fits the profile they're looking for,
whether it's Fox News or CNN,
you know,
and also the information is there.
You know,
there are a fantastic documentaries,
articles being written about all of these conflicts.
People aren't reading them
well with something like Venezuela that the real problem is you have two sides.
If two different versions of what's happening and it's,
if you're,
if you're not educated in that country and you don't understand their politics,
it's very difficult to figure out who's telling the truth.
Yeah.
Same in Syria.
And you know,
I,
I agree with you that I don't,
I don't necessarily think we're getting stupider or dumber in this country or in
the world in general because of the Internet,
but we're definitely getting weirder in our perceptions of actual world events.
And I think,
um,
every time something had like mass shootings,
for instance,
like New Zealand,
every time one of these tragedies takes place,
you see more and more division as I watch people fight over it on Twitter,
people blaming leftwing people,
people blaming right wing people,
people trying to find some reason.
And this one is particularly disturbing because it,
it appears that at least one of the guys,
I don't know their names,
I don't know if they even released,
uh,
have they withheld the names of these guys who have done this?
I haven't seen the names.
I fought in it.
One of them seems like he's trolling.
Like he,
he thanked Pewdie Pie and instead that Candice Owens was as big as inspiration
and he's doing that.
I guess we could agree.
Some people are saying that that,
okay sign is a white power side.
I know we had this dispute with Tim Pool where he was saying,
I guess it is a game that some people do play.
What does it call the game?
The look,
I don't know if there's an official name.
There's some game where if you look under the table you see someone doing that.
There are a lot of punch you or something.
Something stupid like that.
I saw the Steven Miller photo where he's doing up his blazer and supposedly
doing the white the evidence enough.
No,
and there was a woman in court too that was doing that where she had her hand
like this and people are saying that.
But that's what people are talking about rather than,
right.
Which is ridiculous.
Like Ah,
evidence,
evidence.
But this guy in custody is clearly making that symbol clearly.
So like what is he,
you know,
he's like some troll murderer,
some troll mass murderer,
and he's both,
he's both fucking with everybody and a cold blooded ruthless killer of people
that were praying.
Yeah,
I mean I think let's not lose sight of that.
You have to have some serious hatred to walk into a mosque and gunned down.
He's a TTP blend.
Seven people in the other way,
you know?
That's,
yeah,
it's horrific across the board,
top to bottom.
It's,
it's horrific.
But it's also one of those things where like we,
we see so many of these now that we're,
we're starting to get numb.
Whether it's a,
a Jewish synagogue,
whether it's a,
you know,
a Muslim temple,
whether it's a gay club where,
where whatever it is,
it's like you see so many of these mass murders now that it's just,
whether it's a school or a movie theater.
I'd like,
fuck man.
It's just,
it all,
like you were talking about when you were filming the news and you're,
you're there,
you're watching the bullets fly by.
You hear them fly by your head and you are just watching it through the Lens.
We're many,
many,
many levels removed from that and we're sitting here trying to figure out what
to do and we're not there.
We're not where the boats and the people that are there where the bullets take
place,
they try to give you a description of it and even they barely can comprehend
what happened.
But also as you said,
we're going straight to the argument about who to blame.
Right?
He follow rather than,
yes.
I mean if people spend as much time as they spend arguing on Twitter reading,
You know,
I know people say fake news,
you know that there are people who who you can trust if they write a 10,000 word
piece on Syria for the New Yorker for example,
like you know that they're,
they're being fact check and maybe it would be better if there was a website
where you,
we curated all of like the bulletproof,
that's a terrible way to describe it.
But you know,
lock solid rock,
solid investigative journalism's that are 100% ethical that you could completely
rely on for an accurate assessment of what's happening.
Because it is difficult for people and when people,
they rely on biased websites,
which many of them do,
whether it's biased to the left or bias to the right,
things get even more money.
And there's so many of them.
It's so easy to get so easy to reinforce your confirmation bias.
Wa,
whatever,
you know,
whether it's left wing or right wing,
just find that website,
read the comments.
These are my people.
They think like me.
And especially now.
I mean,
it used to be if you were conservatively in the,
you'd read the Wall Street Journal,
a few liberal leading New York Times now,
no matter how far off the scale you are,
you can find a pretty professional looking website.
Yes.
We'll write a story backing up.
You're prejudice and people aren't looking at the story thinking,
okay,
I'm going to find that what happened here.
Yeah.
They're thinking,
I know what my gut feeling tells me I need to find a head,
not even a story,
a headline that justifies my gut feeling about this.
And that's as far as it seems to go.
Now,
you as a journalist,
as a person who risked their life to bring this information to people,
how does this make you feel?
I mean,
there's this part of the reason why you needed to do that Mtma therapy,
not just the fact that you were,
you know,
you're,
you're really are without better useful,
without a better term shell shocked,
right?
I mean you're,
you're there,
you're there.
Yeah.
There's something that comes out of that that's got to be very,
very difficult to recover from.
And overcome.
Yeah.
But there's also the fact that you're going over there and bringing this shit
back and it doesn't seem to,
people don't seem to give a fuck.
And that used to be what kept you going is as you thought,
like some of my work is going to make some kind of difference and when that
starts to fade and you start to think,
that's not going to happen.
That's,
I'm sure your work makes a lot of difference to the people that pay attention to
it.
That I think we're,
we're overwhelmed by bullshit.
I think it's everywhere.
There's,
I know what I mean.
Bullshit.
I mean like nonsense.
You know,
Kim Kardashians psoriasis is in the front page of CNN or something like that.
You know what I mean?
It's not nonsense to her,
but you know what I mean?
Like there's,
there's stuff that people are concentrating on.
It's like Jesus Christ.
It's,
I mean,
yeah,
one of our,
one of our docs on Hbo,
um,
if it got 4 million views,
I think that would be considered very good viewing figures.
Yeah.
That's China.
The country of 360 million people.
Yeah.
Well,
it's very difficult to get people to watch documentaries on real world events.
You get them to watch documentaries on like a sex call from Oregon or something
like that.
Like wow.
Wild country that probably got 10 million.
Yeah.
It's just,
I don't know,
man,
you know,
this New Zealand thing really hiding me,
rattled I,
and you know what is also strange,
people like seem to demand a response.
They'd demand,
um,
people in the public eye to talk about it and you know,
say thoughts and prayers or something like that.
But as soon as you say thoughts and prayers,
they'll say they'll go crazy egg.
We had that for years and that's actually happened.
It's,
yeah.
Yeah.
It's um,
it's very strict,
but like,
like I don't know if they,
they're concerned that you're not horrified.
They want to make sure you are like,
who the fuck isn't,
like,
how could you not be,
I don't understand this.
Or is it just,
they're just frustrated,
confused themselves.
So just lashing out at any target they can find or anyone they can find.
And also,
you know,
I mean I know the footage is available of,
of,
you know,
this guy's head cam as he,
as he shot everybody,
but,
but footage like that has been widely available for a long time now and I think
that's,
that's had a massive,
nothing effect.
I mean,
you know,
the,
the picture of the Syrian refugee washing up on the beach,
you know,
it felt like that was going to have an effect.
It felt like that was the picture that was really gonna gonna change things.
No,
I'm not sure.
It did in might off for a couple days.
Yeah.
And then more news,
you know,
I mean not,
just to be not completely pessimistic that when you're doing stuff for vice and
HBO,
you do get young people reaching out to you and saying,
oh,
I had no idea.
I don't want to be a photographer or a doctor.
Or maybe that's an effect that's going to be felt down the road.
I don't know.
It feels like there are th th th there is a generation of people growing up
thinking I'm not going to play by the normal set of rules like I am going to
actually try and do something about this.
I think I really do believe you do have an effect.
I think vice certainly has an effect.
I think a lot of this has an effect.
I think it's very,
very difficult to feel that effect if you're not experiencing it personally.
I mean to,
to just look out onto the landscape and say how much of an effect is this having
on people?
It's hard.
Like where are you getting the feedback from?
How you,
how are you gauging whether or not this is changing people's perceptions?
Well sometimes the feedback you do get is is on Twitter we'll get,
a few lunatics will say,
oh you fake this footage.
So then you think,
wow,
really having no impact.
But I think that's an argument for just not reading the comments.
There's a little bit of that.
And then,
you know,
I had Renee duressed on recently and she's done a lot of work covering all these
various uh,
Russian troll farms and how they,
uh,
so how they essentially organize conflict online and you know,
they,
they set up these things where you have like a pro Texas movement and they set
them up across the street from a pro Muslim movement and they do it on purpose
and then they have these pro LGBT movement things online to day organize to
attack certain people in certain groups,
diminish certain aspects and defied of the Democratic Party.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
When you hear about shit like that on top of all this,
you're like,
well k the just the,
the actual news itself so difficult to disseminate it.
It's so difficult to figure out what should I pay attention to,
what's real?
And then you have this kind of shit happening on top of that.
You're like,
Whoa,
whoa,
fuck.
You know,
I don't,
you know,
there's a piece came out in the New York and other means that you keep on going
on about the New York about a piece came.
Matt,
how about the New Yorker today by Ed sees it,
a friend of mine about Brexit and about Aaron Banks and,
and,
and I have read the piece yet,
but I know,
I know he's been working on and you know,
there may be evidence that the Russians directly influenced the Brexit vote.
Are the Brexit voters really going to look at that article and think,
Oh,
maybe I was misled.
Maybe I,
maybe I read 10 articles on Facebook that,
that made me vote wrongly.
Eh,
you know,
how many people actually have their minds open enough to consider that?
I mean,
especially with American politics,
it feels like football,
you know,
if your play a foul someone,
of course it's not a fail.
If your player gets fouled,
I sublet foul,
he should get sent off.
It's 100%
blatant tribalism.
Yeah.
Very few objective people.
Very few legitimate centrists.
Everyone seems to be digging their heels in on one side or the other and it
seems to solve that.
A lot of them have just picked a team.
Yeah,
I don't,
I don't necessarily think they've curated these opinions and cultivated these
ideas over many years of soul searching and reading and trying to understand who
they are and how they interface with the world.
I don't think that's happened.
Oh,
your family.
Yes.
Team.
Exactly.
If your family has always been republican suddenly saying,
maybe I'm going to vote for Hillary or Trump feels like coming out with
something,
you know,
like it's that big a deal.
Your occupation,
you know,
depending upon your occupation.
I mean,
good luck finding a job in tech if you're right wing,
you know?
Good.
Good luck working in the arms industry if you're left wing.
Yeah.
It's like,
there's
so weird weird time,
Ben.
Yeah.
You know,
and I,
you know,
I used to,
I always used to read about the,
uh,
the Nixon era,
I think in that must have been a fascinating time to be alive,
but then to actually live through a similar period,
now you're thinking it's not,
it's not fascinating.
He's just,
it's just depressing.
Every single day.
Nixon
thing,
it must have been an insanely difficult to get information.
Right.
You relied on rolling stone,
New York Times,
whatever Washington Post,
whatever newspaper was covering,
whatever store you relied on all those,
but you,
you couldn't get it any other way.
Now you can get it from everything.
I mean there's people on the ground that are tweeting about things and then they
become local celebrities.
So they become sort of like temporary internet journalist slash.
Celebrities.
Yeah.
Fucking weird waiting when you,
you,
your perspective and your,
your life experience is so much richer and deeper in this than anybody else's d
do you think there's a way to turn this around?
Does this going to eventually
even out?
I hope so.
Um,
right now I don't see what that,
what that looks like,
what that looks like is the best way to describe it.
What does that look like?
I mean,
you know,
my attention span I think has been shortened.
Yeah.
I'll sit down to watch a movie at home and within 10 minutes I'm reaching for my
phone.
Yes.
I'm not a heart surgeon.
There's no emergency that you know.
Right,
right.
It might be just be checking Twitter again.
Um,
so it's a perfect storm,
yeah.
Of distractions and we now know it is,
it is addictive.
So yeah.
How you turn that around.
I,
I mean,
it feels like there's a little bit of a movement of people to,
you know,
switch that stuff off and just read a book or go for a walk or,
but yeah,
you got to have real discipline now.
I mean,
you're fighting against our fucking heroin addiction,
man.
Yeah.
It's crazy.
And everyone else is addicted to oh yeah.
So you're not part of the conversation if you're not,
man,
I walked into a restaurant the other night and everyone was looking at their
phone.
No one was looking at each other.
I'm like,
I'm in a movie.
This is a movie.
Some poster.
Public toilets.
Some.
Yeah.
I mean if,
if instead of looking at their phones,
if everyone was just looking at the sky,
you'd be like,
oh my God,
there's a real problem and these people are sick.
Yeah.
Something wrong.
You know,
if everybody's just sitting there with our hands open,
like staring up at this guy and sitting next to each other,
you'd be like,
these people are sick,
there's something wrong.
They need help.
Instead they're,
they're looking at nothing.
Yeah.
They're checking their feed over and over again.
Someone's complaining about Captain Marvel being a woman.
Yay.
Yeah.
And all the experts are they the ones getting followed on there?
Oh,
they're not experts and the experts in whatever,
you know,
the ones who really are we looking at them,
it should be this,
this free flow of information where you can find out anything in your hand.
What an incredible thing.
Yeah.
But it's,
it's not that.
It's definitely not that well.
I think there's two things.
I think,
one we didn't earn it is just given to us.
Right.
It's not like we did all the work to curate all this technology and put it
together and figuring out how to implement it and our deal.
No,
we just went to the fucking Verizon store and picked up a new phone.
I mean,
that's,
that's what most people are doing.
Yeah.
And because of that,
it's almost like being um,
like a trust fund kid or something like that.
It's just all given to you.
It's all handed to you all this,
I felt,
I feel the same way sometimes about weapons.
I feel like the discipline required to learn how to use one and create it and
build it and then understand the responsibility of actually using it on a human
being.
All that shit's out the window.
You just go to the store and buy it.
You know?
There's no requirements of you other than you never killed anybody yet.
Have you written,
driven over anybody in your car?
No.
If you're robbed a bank,
no.
Okay.
Yeah.
You beating your wife?
No.
Okay,
here.
Here's a guy.
Yeah,
it's fucking strange.
And this as,
as a human being,
the,
the lack of discipline and accountability that,
that we have in this ultimate access to all these things constantly and many of
them become just massive distractions.
And yeah,
this in some ways is,
is the utopia that people have dreamed for Django for generation.
Sure.
Free of war.
You're not going to get attacked in your house tonight,
you're not going to starve.
You have everything you could possibly need.
So you'd think we would become the perfect human beings and the absence will
those things that would have killed us in the past or would have made life hard
in the past.
Yeah.
And again,
that's that.
That's not what we're doing well.
I don't think we operate very well without legitimate conflict,
without legitimate conflict in terms of like actual things you need to worry
about.
Like I,
when I used to live in the east coast,
one of the things that was really noticeable was that when it snowed out,
people were nicer.
They help people and they're broken down the side of the road.
There were nice to each other.
There was a sense of vulnerability that we were all deeply entrenched in this
winter nature thing and we've got to work together,
otherwise we can't survive.
Yeah.
You know,
and I think that applies to all aspects of life that when there's no real
danger,
people become extremely frivolous.
Yeah.
It's amazing how quickly we become lazy and complacent.
And actually the flip side of the negative stuff I was saying earlier,
some good days I'll come back from Yemen,
Syria,
wherever.
I'll go out and get a cup of coffee,
we get coffee and I'll read the newspaper.
I'll kept donor and I'll think,
man,
I'm the luckiest man alive.
Yeah.
The flip side,
the fact that I can do this,
this,
you do experience these horrific environment so you can appreciate it.
Yeah.
And the fact that we can,
you know,
I mean within a few hours here we could have one of the best meals.
Yeah.
Possibly in the world we could,
you know,
it's,
that's Fetty incredible.
So on good days that you can,
you can,
you can appreciate that.
Again,
this is you coming from these bad things,
so it puts it in perspective.
Sorry.
Yeah,
I was trying to try it back you up and say,
yeah,
like if you,
if you're not,
if you're not protected and all that stuff,
then you can get to appreciate the basics.
Again,
I was on this trip and Prince of Wales,
we camped out on this island.
It rained every day for six days,
seven days.
I mean we were soaked,
you're soaked,
everything is soaked your sleeping bag so you tent soaked.
Everything came back home and it felt so good.
Like I'd never felt the sun like that before.
Like the sun was just this like this magic love glow that the sky was pouring
down on the city.
Everything felt so happy and I realized like,
well you can't really appreciate this until it's taken away from you.
Yeah,
it's taken away from you.
Then you understand what it is.
So then you wonder when the kids of today grow up,
right.
What are they going to be like when everything has just been at their fingertips
from day one forever for APP,
no mystery.
They don't understand bullshitters either because like,
like when I was a kid,
people just a lie about shit and you really didn't know.
You're like,
man,
I don't know.
He seems like he's full of Shit.
You couldn't just yet.
I have to go to an encyclopedia and you know,
and actually read the,
now you can go,
okay,
what year did this happen?
And you pull up your phone,
get the fuck out.
You know,
people lie about being in the Olympics,
they lied about this,
they lied about that.
Yeah.
It's um,
it's good in that we have ultimate access to information for people that use it
and understand what it is and appreciate it.
It is good.
But to your point,
if there was a way to actually filter and say this is verifiable,
this,
this contains seven things,
which are absolutely bullshit.
We have no doubt about that whatsoever.
If that could exist.
Wonderful.
But I mean folks,
I've tried it.
A few people have tried it,
used to,
it still feels like you end up being described as,
you know,
big on one side of the fight.
I almost feel like we need some sort of organized discipline,
like maybe like a mandatory volunteer work,
cleaning up impoverished communities are mandatory volunteer work doing.
But I don't want people to have to do things like,
um,
I'm conflicted on that too.
I don't want people to have to do that.
You know,
like when there's countries that have mandatory military service,
they seem to have an amazing feeling of,
uh,
of patriotism in those countries and appreciation in those countries because
they actually do have to join the military for two years or whatever it is
going.
I'll have that over here.
Yeah.
Weird.
And to your point about going up and cleaning up,
cleaning up in an impoverished area,
at least then you'd get to meet other people.
Yeah.
People outside of your circle and your Bible.
I mean,
the amount of times here when you talk to people about Muslims,
LGBT,
whatever it is,
and you think,
oh,
it's because you've never met anyone rise and you've actually never met anyone
that is x,
y or zed,
which is,
um,
I moved to Brooklyn in five years or six years ago on a move to Clinton Hill,
Fort Greene.
I got a few friends that have been there forever and I said,
let,
this probably sounds like a really stupid thing to say,
but it feels kind of segregated here.
And they like,
Duh,
it costs.
It does.
And I couldn't believe it.
You know,
I'd grown up on the spike Lee movies and I mean,
I guess they do show a kind of segregation by thought.
Yeah.
This was the place where everyone lived together on the same month,
each other's egos in restaurants.
And I lived on the dividing line between the bit that was a gang gentrified and
the projects you go two blocks that way,
pretty much all black.
You got three blocks that way.
Pretty much all white with yoga studios and Bougie coffee shops and pet spars
and,
and the two communities just did not mix.
It wasn't necessarily they hated each other or they just did not make different
language,
different everything.
Right.
This is the terpene perception that there is a place where everybody's cool.
Yeah.
And I thought it might be New York,
it might be Brooklyn.
And you know,
it's probably the only place that's close,
right?
Like we will at least it has the reputation for it because at least in Brooklyn,
people walk around.
I mean,
yeah.
But,
but talking about amazing pieces of journalism over the last few years,
there's Nicole,
Hannah Jones wrote a piece about a New York school system,
public school system,
the most segregated school system in America when New York really,
and she had to get her daughter into a public school.
And the choice was the very good well supported school in the gentrifying,
mostly white area or the bad failing public school in the non gentrified,
mostly black area where her kids education might suffer.
And I think I'm remembering correct correctly,
but her and her husband had a real fight about it cause she said,
no,
we've got to put our kid in the,
in the bad failing school and help it get better and it's going to take years
and our daughter may suffer in the short term,
but that's what we have to do if we're living in this neighborhood.
Um,
it's an incredible piece.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's a real conflict as a pet.
Do you have children?
No one's possible.
Yeah,
I'm sure.
Right.
You're,
when you're thinking of your children,
you're,
you're always thinking to their safety.
You're always worried about them.
And you want to protect them.
So putting them in a situation where they wouldn't be as protected is never your
first instinct.
Oh,
she,
she was in,
in town hall meetings where,
you know,
progressive white liberal parents who would be very left wing on every other
issue.
We're really fighting to make sure their kid went to the good majority white
school.
Um,
and you know,
they want a bit of diversity but not,
not too much diversity.
Right.
They want a black friend.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's when people think of Brooklyn,
they do think of it as being like the most diverse place.
Yeah.
And it's,
yeah.
Street by street segregated Atlanta is pretty diverse.
Atlanta is interesting,
you know,
because Atlanta has,
um,
a lot of,
there's a,
there's a lot of um,
pause a lot of everything in Atlanta,
but it's,
it's a very black city and a lot of ways,
but it's also a very white city.
You see a lot of black and white people hanging out together and clubs and bars
and restaurants and stuff and it's really like much closer to like a 50,
50 split.
Then a lot of places,
at least in some of the neighborhoods that I've been to,
when I got back to London,
this was one of the few things I'm proud of about,
about London.
Yes.
He certainly New York,
it,
it's not a big deal for a group of friends,
a family,
and kind of to be,
to be genuinely mixed his sites that
you would know.
Um,
I'd ask you is that because London didn't experience slavery the way the United
States did?
Um,
yeah.
I mean obviously we have,
you know,
colonial history,
right?
Of course.
But that wasn't in the country itself for a very long time.
We've had a huge Pakistani Bangladeshi,
Jamaican community and it's,
it's,
you know,
I mean here,
if you have black friends or you date a black girl or you know,
it's,
people think you're trying to prove your work right there.
It was just normal,
normal,
say London.
I'm not saying England's person in London.
I experienced that when I was in London as well.
It seemed like way more integrated.
Yeah.
That,
and that's still five,
six years after I moved to New York.
It's,
it's,
there's still a surprise every day to reinforce a different animal.
Now New York is so fucking expensive.
It's so strange.
And,
uh,
my friend,
Judah,
Judah Freelander who lives there,
so he's,
he's lived there for a long time.
He's like,
it's so changed.
It used be like a lot of artists and a lot of creative people and he goes this
now it's all finance people.
Like every,
you go to finance,
everybody just wants the most expensive suit and the most expensive watch and
they live in this ridiculously expensive apartment.
And I thought that went out in the 80s.
I thought that was like Wall Street Americain that's still very much exist.
That's still prevalent.
Well,
I was talking to this guy yesterday who was a 26 year old who's graduating with
a degree in finance and trying to figure out what he wants to do and he's
thinking about moving to New York and getting a job in Wall Street,
but he's hesitant cause he's a nice guy.
He doesn't want to go dark,
you know?
And I'm like,
it could,
you could go to the dark side.
Like these people are,
look,
not all of them,
but a lot of them are just straight up materialists.
They're just chasing money.
When you're in the money business and you're just chasing money,
like there's your reward is things.
Your award is objects and status and clothes and houses and shit.
Yeah.
And sometimes you talk to those guys and you say,
so what?
What do you do?
I work in finance.
Yeah.
But what do you actually do?
Work in finance.
And I'm very well rewarded,
as you can see.
Yeah.
But what do you actually do?
I look for fluctuations in international grain markets.
Oh,
congratulations.
What an amazing thing to dedicate your life to him.
You know?
And if you just said what they do rather than what the reward was,
right.
I think this is ridiculous.
What a waste of your time it is.
But the,
the status of being super wealthy,
for a lot of them,
it's worth it because of that.
They don't have a passion,
right.
They don't have a thing there.
Dinner trying to write a book.
They're not trying to make a painting or whatever the fuck it is.
You know,
they're just trying to make the money and they're making the money.
So everything is great.
Yeah.
They,
the coke and I mean,
if,
if I pulled up,
hey her in a,
you know,
pop a Lamborghini with a diamond studded watch and be like,
look at this one,
what the fuck are you must be wrong people.
Yeah.
But not that many people would be,
would be that impressed.
I think most people would think what a what a tool.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's certain circles,
right?
It's whatever circle that you're in.
Certain circles.
I can finance circles.
It is about those things more than it's not because those things represent
success in your industry.
Your friends should read a piece of [inaudible] in a book by Michael Lewis,
um,
and he talks to a bunch of graduates who you know,
are about to get approached by the big banks and financial institutions.
He says,
listen,
you think you're going to do this for two or three years and a few million
dollars and then do something worthwhile with your life.
But what's going to happen is you're going to get seduced and you're going to
get the mortgage and you're going to,
suddenly 20 years of your life will have gone by and you'll think,
what the fuck have I just done with?
This is the exact advice I gave him yesterday.
The exact advice.
I was like,
man,
you got to do something that actually makes you happy.
Don't get sucked into that.
And he was saying,
I was thinking of trying it for a few years.
That's what they say.
Yeah,
man.
Once you,
once you get a mortgage,
once you get a car,
yeah.
Ooh,
nice BMW.
How much that run your month.
Yeah.
Ah,
fuck man.
Yeah.
It's,
um,
it's a strange thing to the stock market,
the moving around of numbers and looking for fluctuations in the market.
And the fact that what drives me crazy is when you hear that people have gotten
servers that are the closest as possible to the market because that the ping,
because they're,
they're using algorithms so that everything is done off of a computer program
and the closer they are,
the quicker that transaction takes place and it actually can be to the tune of
millions of dollars.
That's another Michael LewisLewis' book.
Yeah.
Oh is it flash boys?
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
These guys figured out what was going on.
And then they started a,
um,
a trading floor where there was so much cable that no one could benefit from
those,
you know,
those nanoseconds and the passage,
the other banks tried to close it down and it wasn't that popular.
Jamie was telling me that there's a game called Fort and all the kids play and
they're moving to Columbus,
Ohio so that they can be closer to the server.
But that's one of the places in Texas,
also in others.
So another place where they move to same deal.
Yeah.
To be closer to the server so that they could ping lower cause it's like a real
business.
Yeah.
But at least these guys are playing a game.
It's a skill.
I mean there,
I don't know,
I guess it's a skill
that someone made $100,000 yesterday,
but yeah.
Yeah.
So I,
I tend on ESPN last night trying to watch the boxing those books at Madison
Square Garden last night.
And Espn,
the main channel had gamers in a stadium playing,
playing football on the computer.
They have an east sports arena in Vegas right at the luck sore.
It's like an e sports arena.
They got the franchise fees for the next season of call of duty or $25 million a
team,
which is like four guys on a team.
She's playing the game and someone's gotta pay for that.
Jesus Christ.
You were in Dallas for the IRL Spence.
Mikey Garcia fine.
Yeah.
Earl Spence is the real deal.
I mean,
I thought Mikey Garcia went out,
books him for a few rounds at least,
um,
early on.
And then maybe,
you know,
Spencer's size and power would make a difference.
But yeah,
Buxton from when I looked at them in the weigh ins,
I was like,
yikes.
Yeah,
he's a lot bigger.
Yeah.
To weight divisions.
Well Mike,
he started his career at one,
what was it,
one 35 he was featherweight champ,
I think it was his first.
Oh,
so lighter than that.
So it was at one 26 see pool.
Pull that up.
Mike Garcia c they fought at 47 and Earl Spence looks every bit of one 47 I
mean,
he's a big fella.
He looks like he could fight one 54 easy.
You know,
Mike Garcia just looks so much smaller than him at the wedding,
but it wasn't just the size.
It's like,
yeah,
Errol sprints,
juniors,
just the real deal.
That was the surprise for me.
Yeah,
he was incredible.
He's fucking good.
He's so smart too.
Like when you hear him talk,
he's so smooth.
Do you remember the smiley,
he's smiling.
Trinidad fun.
Yes I do.
It reminded me that,
yeah,
look at the size difference and he would have put on a load of weight
in the next day.
Six hours as well.
Yeah.
I mean,
he's a,
he's taller,
he's wider,
he's more muscular and he's probably pretty dehydrated making the way it looks
there.
Roberto Duran having a time.
It was alive.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He was dancing at the weigh ins and shit with certain fighters were dancing and
he was dancing to,
it was pretty funny.
What is he doing now?
Is He,
you like working as a,
Oh,
he's helping them promote these things.
Is that what's going on?
He was on this one.
Yeah,
he was there.
We saw a ringside.
He's so beloved.
He's,
what a crazy story that guy had.
Right.
Like to go for that dot.
No Mas fight.
He was,
he was shunned.
I mean hated.
Yeah.
Mass shame across the whole world for years until he beat Davey Moore.
That's one of my favorite fights of all time.
It's brutal.
Brutal.
Just to see that tenacity just slowly come and I read a story that Tyson was at
that fight with all of his friends from Brooklyn and they couldn't afford
tickets so they just rushed the security gate knowing that three or four of them
would get cool real and the others were getting and that's how he'd go in.
Yeah.
Wow.
I remember watching that fight thinking that he was going to lose and I was a
big Roberto Duran fan and I'll say,
God man,
he's probably going to lose.
He was supposedly is right.
He the sure and he fucked Davey Moore up.
Davey more wound up dying a crazy accident where he was working on his car in
his driveway and it fell on him.
Yeah,
he,
it fell on him or at random over like one of those things and he was trying to
fix his car.
Something fucked up like that.
And Duran laced in at one point when he started the leather laces.
Yup.
He thumbed him too.
They think that's what you remember his eyes swollen up pretty bad.
That's one of the fights that makes me feel a bit guilty about loving boxing.
When you,
when you see that,
cause it's so true to fucking businessman.
It's a brutal business,
you know?
I mean,
I don't know if MMA is more brutal.
I think it probably is,
but there's a lot of pokes.
The eye in MMA a lot and most of them are on,
they're unintentional,
most of them,
but a bunch have to be intentional.
I think that gets me the MMA is because I come from books and he's is my sport.
When you see a guy go down and he's clearly out and the guy jumps on him and
pounds him,
I know sometimes the ref tries to get into that.
That's just a bit too much for me.
It's this weekend or a doll.
He knocked out Darren tell and he koom he,
he clipped him with a left hand on the way down.
He hit him with another left hand and then Darren till is flatline completely
out and mosfet out on corks.
A bomb right on his face while he's out cold.
It was rough.
I mean,
correct me if I'm wrong,
but I feel like a books in crowd appreciates a good skillful technical match.
And I feel like sometimes a UFC crowd will be cheering at that moment you just
described.
I think humans like brawls,
I mean there's a reason why all Touro Gadi and Micky Ward was such a successful
trilogy is because those guys would just beat the fuck out of it.
Yeah,
there were so closely matched and they were both these blood and guts warriors
and they just stood in front of each other and they were,
and we knew at the that these
guys are not going to beat Floyd Mayweather to not going to beat the best guys
there.
You know,
they're good fighters,
worldclass fighters,
but they're not world champions.
And there's a thing that we look at when we watch fighters.
Like fighter could be good,
but there's a,
there's a fighters that we appreciate,
but they'll never fight for the world title.
If they do,
they have no chance.
And then there's fighters.
Like this guy might be the best in the world.
You know there's a difference,
you know,
and you could buy a Floyd.
It's defensive skills,
but he's never going to have that.
That wall with Micky ward or archer or gas.
He like never,
but he's also going to be fine.
When he's 55 he'll be able to talk and walk and you know,
nothing happens to them.
To him,
his,
he's not.
He doesn't,
he didn't endure the punishment in the beatings that those guys had.
That's the saddest of all is when you see these guys,
you see them on television,
you see the war,
you see the F,
but you don't see the aftermath.
You don't see the struggles that they have with their memory.
You don't see the,
the confusion,
the anger out of nowhere.
The emotional outbursts where they don't,
they don't know why they're doing what they're doing.
They don't why they're saying what they're saying.
Most of them are broke before they even retired.
Yup.
Yeah,
yeah.
Did you see the film about Michael Ben?
It just came out on Netflix as part of that loses series?
No,
I did not.
That's,
that's worth watching.
He,
um,
he never really liked boxing and everybody wanted to box but has got a really
successful career in Hollywood producing plays and movies.
Yeah.
It's like,
it's a great,
Michael Bent produces plays and movies play I think.
And he teaches a act as how to how to box as well when they're doing movies.
It's a great little talk.
Good for him.
Well,
I'm always very happy when someone finds a path,
you know,
you just get the sense that boxing was never him and he found a way at the end
to be him and do something he loved and he's thriving at it,
which,
which is a rare thing for Xbox.
It's crazy when people are just good at things.
There's a guy in MMA like that,
Anthony Rumble Johnson who was one of the most terrifying fighters in the
history of the sport just to ruthless knockout artists.
And um,
last his last loss,
he w I was talking to him in the octagon.
I was interviewing him and he said,
I know I don't like fighting.
I'm not a fighter.
He goes,
I'm an athlete,
I'm just good at it.
And I was like,
wow,
that is a crazy honest,
like and such an introspective way of like,
he's like looking at themselves like,
look it,
this is not what,
I don't want to do this.
Yeah.
But since then he's thought about coming back.
But people say to me all the time,
your adrenaline junkie or addicted to the thrill.
I'm like,
there's no fucking thrilled doing this.
What you think?
It's a thrilling I note and no question.
I'm sure there's no thrill for you.
But do you think that being in these incredibly tense environments ramps life up
in a way that you don't get outside of it?
Like,
did you,
did you read tribe?
Sebastian younger and I met him a few times as well.
He was,
he was,
when I was having a few problems,
he was very helpful.
He was,
wasn't he really good guy?
I really liked that guy.
Yeah.
Uh,
yeah.
Before I met him.
I mean,
he's got that picture in vanity fair,
like posing with the dog tag and it's like a muddle looking picture
guide were tosser.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And then I met him and he was the nicest,
most humble,
considerate guy.
He's,
he's fantastic.
And I really like that book as well.
Yeah.
I couldn't,
I couldn't be a bigger fan of hers as a human to just,
just very genuine really there when you're talking to him.
But that's sort of his take on it is that,
um,
and if you're listening,
I know I talk about that book too much.
Uh,
I just love it,
but his take on it was that these people are experiencing life in this
incredibly extreme environment and then they come back to the rest of the world.
It just doesn't feel real anymore.
So it's not,
it's not thrilling when you're there,
but it is real drama.
You're seeing life and death drama right in front of your face.
So when you come back,
you think you really want to see this person and see this film and try out this
new restaurant and then you get back and you just each,
you don't care.
He's just feels flat.
Yeah.
I mean,
you know,
when,
when I was getting the PTSD treatment,
numb,
numbness was the word that came out.
More numbness to everything,
like numbness to the danger when you're there,
but numbness back here for the things that should be pleasurable and should be
providing some kind of relief as well.
Now,
how did the pts PTSD treatment and get organized as this through maps?
Are you part of that study?
Yeah,
we did,
uh,
did a short film about,
about Rick Doblin and this,
this,
you know,
there's this effort to,
to get MTMA legal.
Um,
but I'd been in denial for years and years.
Then a new producer joined vice guy called Steven Bailey and we had the first
idea where he was pitching some,
some the first meeting when he was pitching some of his ideas.
And he mentioned,
you know,
this breakthrough therapy using MTMA for PTSD.
And I just in voluntarily put my hand up and said I'll do it straight away and
was like,
gave me an excuse to actually,
you know,
get some help and see if I had something done MTMA recreationally before that.
I mean,
yeah,
I came of age in London in the 90s,
you know,
he had like,
it was like having a pint of beer.
Then what is the difference between doing it in a therapeutic environment?
I mean it's,
I,
it's,
it's Mtma assisted therapy.
The emphasis is on the therapy.
So you're lying in a bed if you've fasted for 24 hours before the therapist
knows you and knows your issues.
So knows how to like politely,
gently nudge you towards the right topic of conversation,
but always makes it,
makes you actually get to the conclusions.
Um,
you know,
there were times when I will ask him,
why is this happening?
Why do I think this?
And He'd put it back on me and make me put two and two together.
Um,
sometimes you listen to music,
sometimes you put an eye mask on and you don't sleep,
but you just,
you know,
have a quiet 20,
30 minutes.
But it's a,
it's a very intense seven to eight hour therapy session and the MD may just
enables you to get the benefits.
And all of the veterans and first responders who took part in the first round of
trials had been therapy resistant.
Um,
and I think the first round,
I think 72% of them got the benefits and we're considered PTSD free after,
after the three month trial.
So during the three month trial,
how many experiences do they have?
One a month.
One a month or three?
Three total.
Yeah.
I mean the best,
the best example I can give of how this works,
I had,
the first veteran I met had been through it.
He had one session and he'd lost some friends in Iraq and it felt guilty about
it and always thought maybe if I'd done something different that could have
saved them.
And he imagined being them in in the first MDA session and they were saying to
him,
why are you ruining your life?
You're alive,
you're healthy.
We want you to have a fun,
productive,
full life and enjoy your friends,
enjoy your family.
And he said that gave him permission and that was what he needed.
And he didn't even do the second two sessions.
Wow.
What an interesting way of looking at it of course.
And that word permission because there is so much guilt and you're just getting
permission to just give yourself a bit of a pattern.
The survivor self or breaking is a real oh yeah.
Yeah.
A lot of people that come back from the war that lost friends have that horrible
feeling that it should've been them.
That they're not as good as the person who died or that somehow or another them
being alive is the reason why their friend was dead.
Irrational thoughts or maybe I didn't really experience it because I came out
unscathed.
Um,
yeah,
which is one of the reasons why I didn't seek treatment for years and years and
years.
Cause I've got friends who lost their legs.
I've got friends who were kidnapped and killed,
you know,
so maybe I've only just dipped my toes so there's nothing,
nothing.
I've got nothing to complain about.
What was your number one issue?
Um,
I think the numbness to danger and to pleasurable things back here.
I mean like my,
my camera man in Mosul,
we were there when the Iraqi army beat Isis and it was,
I mean it was house to house fighting.
We were stepping on bodies to get through rooms.
And at one point,
um,
I was with,
we were with three or four Iraqi soldiers trying to get to the river to cut off
these two isis positions.
And they've got a radio message saying there's a suicide bomber and a gunman
running down the street towards you now.
So we stepped into this,
what used to be a shop that was all blown up and smashed a bit.
And I sat down as the two soldiers tried to shoot the suicide bomber as he was
running towards us and someone said Id id.
And right next to me under the rubble was an IED.
The day before,
I think,
or two days before to French journalists and Curtis journalist had been killed
when they stepped on an IED trying to get out and have ea Manzano.
My camera man just said,
you look bored.
Um,
and he filmed it like we got that moment on camera and I remember just looking
so bored and I couldn't give a shit about the suicide bomber,
the IED.
I was just bored out of my brains.
And that's when I thought this is,
this is not a natural reaction to what's going on around you right now.
What did you think your natural reaction should have been?
I mean,
blood racing,
racing,
heart rate,
increasing,
you know,
um,
vigilance,
you know,
and what did you think at the time was the cause of you being known?
Like while it was happening,
I hadn't really thought that much about PTSD.
I just thought it'd become so used to this.
And,
and one of the things that came up in the,
in the one of the last sessions I did was I didn't think I was seen as important
enough to get to get shot and hurt and have medics rush over to help me and
maybe a helicopter to take me out.
And,
you know,
um,
and I know that sounds ridiculous now,
but I think part of me thought,
yeah,
you're not important enough to have something so dramatic happened to you.
You're just,
you're just witnessing other people in these dramas.
Wow.
It'd be right next to an IUD and not freaking out is pretty crazy.
Yeah.
With a suicide bomber riding down the street towards,
I mean,
that's,
and also,
you know,
people,
one of the reasons you feel guilty as you do get respect for being brave.
And I would say it wasn't bravery.
I wasn't scared and then did it anyway.
I wasn't scared.
I was just numb and just,
you know,
kept the,
get respect from other journalists,
from the soldiers.
Like who are you getting respect from?
Yeah.
Or,
or people that,
whatever the films.
And,
uh,
it doesn't,
it doesn't feel like bravery.
It just feels like you're,
you know,
you've,
you've become stupid about the risks you're taking.
So talk me through this therapy.
So you're fasting for 24 hours,
you take the Mtma and then they just start talking to you about the things that
are troubling.
Yeah.
So you take 125 milligrams and then when that hits a lot,
I think it's a good dose,
but then when it hits you take another 75.
So overall that's,
that's a good dose.
And that keeps you up for,
you know,
six,
seven,
eight hours.
Um,
and then,
you know,
the therapist would ask very brief question,
just,
just knowing what,
what direction to push me.
And I remember the first session,
I mean,
I'd thought because of what I now know was PTSD,
I'd felt because of the job I do.
And because there was this kind of darkness in there,
I didn't get involved with anyone seriously for a very long time.
And even thought I'm not going to have a family and kids and house and dog.
And you know,
I just just had even thought about it,
just assumed that's not for me because of the job I do.
And very early on in that first session after I resisted it for about an hour
and a half,
like was really resisting it for a long time and thinking it was even a plus
placebo.
Um,
but,
but there was this wave of relief.
I've just,
of course you can of course you can have all that.
And it,
it felt like a revelation.
Wow.
Cause I thought that had been close to me for so long.
I know seven,
eight years,
maybe longer.
I just thought,
no,
you can't do that.
That's not for you or you can't put someone else through that with you.
What is it particularly about Mtma what is it about,
I mean I've,
I've done it but I've only done it once.
The,
is it just because of the fact that it just alleviates the insecurity and allows
you to look at things in a more natural sense?
You look at everything as if we're just talking about having coffee or water,
everything is just easy to think about on a dress and talk about.
Um,
and I think I'll probably explain it badly,
but I think the science of it is you have five networks in your brain.
And,
and I was basically in fight or flight mode so much that that was the only mode
I knew.
So even when I'm back in New York,
if someone walks up to close behind me,
I'm expecting a confrontation.
I mean fight or flight mode all the time.
So your brain is ignoring the other parts of your brain that provide context.
And that say that bang outside is just a car backfiring.
It's not an id or someone shooting.
So the MDA just allows your brain to,
you know,
all the parts of your brain to communicate.
Again,
you're not just in that fight or flight mode.
So once you get out of that fight or flight mode,
you can then address things that,
that you can even begin to address before.
And once you've had these experiences for you,
it was three experiences.
They're profound enough that you retain the benefits.
Some,
I mean it looks like I'm in the 25% that still have PTSD after the three months,
but it still helps enormously.
I mean,
the next day they got me to sit down and do a video diary and I was kind of
saying,
yeah,
I thought this near this was a revelation.
And I said,
you know what,
I'm just,
I'm just smiling now in a way that I don't feel like I've smiled for years.
Like it feels like my whole face is smiling and there's the next day,
which is usually a little wrecked.
Yeah.
I think it's two or three days when you have the,
what we used to call a moody Tuesday.
Oh yeah.
That one at two or three days.
Yeah.
But then with this there,
there's no,
there's no come down with this.
It's,
it's,
you know,
there,
there's no downside how they give,
you know,
they give you five HTP or anything while you're,
um,
nothing apart from the Mtma.
I mean,
wow,
you have,
you have juice,
you have water throughout.
Um,
I mean maybe the come down is related to,
you know,
people that used to take it with just dance and sweat right on lightly hydrate.
Yeah.
Maybe.
Maybe it's just shitty Mtma maybe.
Yeah.
I mean the,
yeah,
the ecstasy they would have sold in London would have been eating rat poison and
breeze block that and all kinds of stuff.
Yeah.
Um,
so I know they're having very positive results with this.
And are they planning on implementing this to the public in any tire short term?
I mean,
is this something that like people that are listening to this right now,
is this going to be available to them fairly soon?
It looks like it should be legal by 2021,
2022,
the third round of officially FDA approved trial start soon.
Um,
that's the first one that involves people other than veterans and first
responders.
If that gets as good results of the first two trials,
which I'm sure it will then,
then I think it's going to be,
and because FDA gave it breakthrough drug status,
there's nothing that you know,
anyone can do to stop it.
It will be legal by 2021 2022 that's very good news for a lot of people that are
suffering.
Yeah.
It's so difficult for people to change perspective just to,
to have a break from the normal sort of momentum of your life and to be able to
stop and analyze.
Yeah.
And that's exactly what it did to me.
I was just in this Rut for so long where there was,
it was impossible to,
to,
to look at things.
Did you think about changing your life?
Yeah,
and I'm thinking about a lot right now.
I mean,
I,
you know,
I thought I would retire after this,
um,
this therapy,
but I think I said it before the,
you know,
in the first session I was planning the next film,
next area.
He's like,
this is still what I want to do.
I've just got to do it smarter.
I've got to take breaks.
I've got to recover in between trips.
Um,
there isn't this pressure to be where people are getting their heads blown off
every single time.
And then the last one I did was about Yemen and we spent a week on the front
lines with the various fighting groups and got the usual crazy fighting footage.
But the powerful stuff was a woman who had her leg blown off by an airstrike and
an IDP camp in a miserable IDP camp where the Saudis Nimrod,
he's a claiming they're providing people with everything they need.
And then at the end,
a child malnutrition clinic right on the front line where a nurse just just
begged all parties to end this war.
And she was,
she was literally on the front line surrounded by a minefield,
couldn't get doctors,
couldn't get supplies,
had a few dozen kids in this clinic that she was just managing to keep alive.
And he's whaling emaciated babies with their rib cages,
caged it caved in.
Um,
and you know,
the reason you do this or to cover the effects of war,
it's not to get crazy for Tj of explosions and shoot outs.
It's the effect of war on civilians.
So maybe the answer is to do that and you know,
not feel this pressure to,
to,
to just get the crazy fighting footage all the time in our country.
Yemen is in many ways,
mostly synonymous for drone attacks.
Drone strikes is when we think about Yemen,
we think about the drawn tracks that we hear about on wedding parties,
the accident,
the,
the number of people that are accidentally kill the civilian casualty rate as
some preposterous number.
Yeah.
I mean,
no one knows because you can't check out most of these areas,
but it's in the tens of thousands at least.
And it's,
the percentage is all so preposterous.
It's far more than 50%.
Right?
Yeah.
I mean it's,
it's air strikes.
So it used to be us drone strikes on,
on al Qaeda assassinates now it's Saudi MRT airstrikes and um,
with,
with us assistance,
I mean,
we were until recently refueling the plane,
supplying the plane,
supplying the weapons.
But yeah,
they've hit weddings,
funerals,
that,
schools,
hospitals.
Um,
and I don't think that's,
that's by accident.
I think they're taking her approach to Yemen,
that,
that we need to crush the opposition,
not take out the military leaders and you can't,
there's no movement in history that been crushed by fourth that never works to
Christ.
When you're over there,
what does it feel like in Yemen as opposed to Afghanistan or other places?
Um,
Yemen,
the actual fighting is,
is much more low intensity.
It's fairly small groups of guys at some distance just lobbing shelves each
other and,
and there's,
you know,
there's snipers and that there are gunfights but it's not as big scalers as Iraq
or Afghanistan,
but there were a regular air strikes that are killing civilians.
Um,
and while the two sides are fighting this,
this slow and bloody war,
um,
the infrastructure is being destroyed and the civilians are unable to get basic
food and medicine.
That,
that's the really shocking thing there.
And also the,
I mean,
I knew that,
that the coalition,
as it's called,
you know,
the,
the fighting groups backed by Saudi Arabia and UAE where American backed,
but you see American stuff everywhere.
I mean m wraps,
you know,
these million dollar bump,
we've trucks,
I've only ever seen American soldiers and marines driving in Iraq and
Afghanistan.
You see them everywhere there.
Um,
and that's a real surprise to see that.
Wow.
How did Yemen become this area that's so synonymous,
withdrawn strikes.
Like why did we approach Yemen differently than any other part of the world in
terms of the,
the,
the allocation drone strikes
there in terms of numbers?
I don't know.
I mean,
I think for a while the only thing the US was doing in Yemen was drone strikes
against al Qaeda.
Um,
but I don't know if there had been more drone strikes in Yemen and then
elsewhere.
I mean,
that's where we killed an American citizen that,
which got lots of headlines on purpose with no trial.
They just seem to,
so we'll do it was because he had joined isis,
is that what it was?
Yeah,
it was,
it was a very well known and popular,
um,
you know,
uh,
online presence,
rallying people to,
to fight.
But the air strikes in,
in,
in Yemen,
uh,
um,
you know,
and,
and you know,
with,
with us weapons are that,
that's,
that's what's really killing people.
And,
and,
and meaning that people can't get,
get food nade there because you just can't move things around there.
Um,
whatever came out of that guy getting killed,
they,
they basically,
no one was punished for it.
I mean,
he's an American citizen.
He was,
I mean,
if it was in America,
if somehow or another this guy was in the suburbs of Chicago and they launched a
drone strike on him,
it would be front page news and it'd be a real issue.
But the fact that was in Yemen,
I mean,
again,
the legacy of Iraq and Afghanistan is that now we're killing guys like him with
drone strikes or special forces raids here and there.
And it's,
it's happening almost in secret.
And no one's saying this appears to be illegal.
I mean,
some people are,
you know,
you can,
you,
you know,
which media outlets you can go to to read about this.
But I think most people are thinking if that's,
if that's the alternative to invasion.
Yeah.
And trillions of dollars and American soldiers coming back with no legs for a
war.
We don't understand.
I think a lot of people are willing to accept it.
I don't agree with it.
But that seems to be what's happening now.
No,
I think you're right.
Um,
the other thing about that is with a lot of these,
even though it does seem to be illegal,
people sort of shrug their shoulders and then no one pursues it and then it just
kinda goes away.
Yeah.
But there's some stories that for whatever reason,
like Jamal Shogi did not go away and still still out there.
Like it was so egregious.
It's so crazy that this guy walks into the embassy yeah.
And just never comes out.
And they're like,
oh no,
what happened?
And then slowly you start getting a different story.
And then apparently there's leaked,
there's audio and perhaps even video of his murder.
Yup.
That ordered by the way,
by someone who was hanging out with Jared questionnaire afterwards,
um,
with apparently no mention of,
of,
of what happened.
Yeah.
As a journalist when you see shit like that,
that has got to hit home.
Uh,
the,
yeah,
the last few years fed for journalists especially,
you know,
if you're,
I mean he wasn't an American citizen,
but he did write for the Washington Post and was a resident.
But,
but I mean I was,
I was,
I was arrested in Iran for a week,
a long,
long time ago and roughly the same time and Iranian Canadian photographer was
arrested and she was raped and beaten to death.
She said that people that are citizens of these countries there,
they're
really,
really bearing the brunt.
Um,
and again,
that's why I'm uncomfortable if people call me brave because I get to come home
with these guys,
you know,
they can get to them and they can get to their families very easily.
And that,
that takes a whole other level of,
of bravery.
And the woman who was raped and beaten to death,
what did,
what was she involved with?
She was a photographer and she was just taking pictures of,
yeah.
Yeah.
And the usual thing with,
I mean certainly in Iran,
but this is common all over the place.
If you're a dual citizen working as a journalist in for example around,
and they'll accuse you of being a spy.
I was accused of being a spy.
They tried to get me to confess to being a spy.
That's a very normal assumption out there.
And how long were you in jail for?
Just seven or eight days.
What was that like?
Actually not,
not too bad.
I mean,
psychologically it was bad because they were threatening torture and execution.
Um,
physically it wasn't,
it wasn't too bad.
I was fed.
Um,
I had a bad bed.
I was roughed up a bit.
I wasn't,
I wasn't beaten.
Um,
but I did think it could last months and months and months.
And I did think I could go to Evin prison,
actually put me in a car and drove me to what they said was in prison once and
then just took me somewhere else.
Evan prison,
even prisoners where people have been tortured and executed.
So they just drove you little scarier.
Drove me around for a few hours to scare me and then took me to another place
here.
What were they trying to get you to confess to being a spy?
And they said at one point they said,
uh,
do you honestly expect us to believe you travel the world collecting all this
information and you don't share it with your government?
I said,
yeah,
that's exactly how it works.
And they thought I was insulting their intelligence by,
by saying that.
What were you over there covering?
We were,
I did a series.
One of the first series I did was called holidays in the axis of evil.
So I spent my first four years as a journalist undercover wearing a secret
camera.
And Luckily I appeared on a couple of docs with a guy who was not very good.
And so I looked genuine next to him.
Um,
so the controller,
BBC Two said,
give this guy a series.
And I was racking my brains trying to think,
wanting to be a foreign correspondent and wanting to cover conflict.
Then George Bush made the axis of evil speech and John Bolton added three
countries to the list.
So it was Iraq,
Syria,
Cuba,
North Korea,
uh,
Libya,
Cuba with a six evil countries.
So we went to all six countries.
Me and one camera man held out,
handheld camera chain,
actually saw it and that's when he first reached out.
And I started talking to vice about eventually joining them,
but kind of documentaries from the streets up to,
we're just trying to say,
you know,
despite all the rhetoric about Iran,
this is what the people are actually like.
And it was,
it was kind of use led.
We,
we interviewed a bunch of students who are involved in some famous protests in
1999 where the police came in and smashed the dormitories and burned them down
and beat them.
I think because we interviewed them,
we would then tracked and arrested.
Oh,
so how'd you get it free?
How do I get,
how'd you get free?
Uh,
it's,
I didn't know at the time,
but if to come 10 countries have diplomatic relations.
It's only a big deal after a week.
So on the night of the seventh day or the,
or the eighth day,
they,
they let me go.
Oh yeah.
I had no idea at the time.
I thought,
I thought this could go on months and months.
A month.
Now when you were over there in around what is their perception of the United
States?
When you talk to the young people over there?
Oh,
uh,
love the United States real music culture,
sports,
everything and extremely well educated about the United States.
Um,
American foreign policy is a completely different discussion,
but I mean,
one of the things we tried to cover was the Friday rally at Tehran University
where you see everyone chanting death to America,
death to Israel.
And we went to cover it because they bus in old men from the countryside.
You sit there going,
ah,
yeah,
death to America,
death to Israel else.
Yet it's not something to be seeking some propaganda staged event.
Yeah.
I mean if there was a turning point in Iraq and Afghanistan wars and with Iran,
Ryan Crocker,
who was the former ambassador to Saudi Arabia,
Israel,
Iraq,
Afghanistan,
straight off the nine 11,
he was sent to Geneva where a number of countries affected by the refugee
crisis.
We're meeting to discuss how to deal with it,
one of the countries that are wrong so that have this meeting.
And then he and his Iranian counterpart would disappear for,
he says seven or eight hours over a to discuss the future of American Iran
relations.
They knew that they were going to get rid of the Taliban.
Um,
so the Uranian said,
okay,
here's a map of the Taliban leaders homes.
If you take out those homes on day one,
Taliban have finished and Ryan Crocker setup.
Thank you.
Can I,
can I take notes from this map?
They said,
the map is yours.
We made it for you.
Gave him the map.
Uh,
let the Americans use Iranian airspace handed over some prisoners.
They were absolutely key in us overthrowing the Taliban so quickly.
And Ryan Crocker was making good progress.
And then talking about the future of Iraq post Saddam,
one night he gets a knock on his door
and two of his staff has come in and say,
boss,
you'll,
you're really not going to like what's just happened.
And he said,
what's just happened?
And it was the axis of evil speech.
So the moderate,
so so-called in Iran who had fought hard to get permission to negotiate with the
Great Satan,
the u s said,
you've made us look stupid.
You know,
it was hard for us to get this chance.
We helped you in Afghanistan.
We were willing to discuss future relations between our two countries and,
and this is,
this is what happens.
So it's over.
Wow.
And then fairly soon after that,
obviously there was the invasion of Iraq and Iran is sponsoring the insurgency
and giving them sophisticated ids and all that rather than,
you know,
potentially helping.
So you think that with wow,
with one speech,
yeah,
the whole thing shifted.
Yeah.
So they would,
they would have been willing to somehow or another and negotiate or cooperate or
I mean at work alongside getting rid of Sudan was obviously in,
in their interests.
You know,
they put a brutal eight year,
eight year with,
we have a very strange relationship with Iran.
I mean,
going back to the hostages from,
you know,
the Jimmy Carter era.
Yup.
I do think it's one of the most misunderstood countries in the region.
I mean,
when you actually go there,
um,
you know,
the people are so smart and so educated and,
and potentially such,
such good allies.
So what is the key issue?
It's the government.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
And you know what I just explained,
I think they're capable of being far more rational than,
than the speeches by the crazy old molars would,
would suggest
they proved it.
Yeah.
And the idea that the Saudis numerati is,
can somehow bomb the huskies in Yemen into submission and push back Iranian
influence on their southern border is,
is ridiculous.
That's just never going to happen.
Um,
and,
and I think even if you ignore the obvious moral argument,
um,
just from a pragmatic point of view,
the idea that we should back this,
um,
unconditionally is ridiculous.
Let's see.
This is just
part of the real problem when you're dealing with world events is trying to
parse all this stuff out and look at so many different stories from so many
different parts of the world in so many different areas of conflict.
And it's almost impossible to pay attention to it all.
Yeah.
Every time I meet people from these countries,
I'm,
I feel like a fraud because there's so much that they know that I don't know and
that I should.
Um,
and you know,
I get paid to do this.
I get paid to pay attention to this for a living and I feel out of my depth
regularly and that's focusing on the five or six countries that I focus on,
that alone.
Everything else.
What other countries do you focus on?
Uh,
I mean,
the last few years it's been Congo quite a bit.
Afghanistan,
mostly Iraq,
uh,
Yemen of focusing on a lot of the last three,
four years.
Um,
they're the main ones.
I've been to Brazil recently,
been to Central African Republic recently,
but,
but
now I've talked to a friend of mine who's from Brazil who has a completely
different take on the new leader of Brazil.
Like he's more positive about it.
And then I've talked to other people that say he's a monster.
Yeah.
Um,
I mean,
if people in Brazil are living through the current chaos,
I can understand why they might go to a detailed,
a type figure to say it's going to be messy,
but he's going to clean it up.
Right.
But he certainly seemed like a monster.
Yeah.
They,
they're experiencing some crazy economic crisis as well,
right?
Yeah.
And it was the fastest growing economy in Latin America was booming.
It was just a few years ago.
So it's like this roller coaster ride.
We did a film there recently and uh,
I met Mike at the numbers slightly wrong,
but the amount of people that were murdered in Brazil in 2017 I believe it was,
was double more than double the amount that were murdered in Syria.
She's 72,000 yeah.
And after the World Cup and Olympics,
the,
the trafficking gangs and the police malicious just retook all of those areas
that were pacified to,
to,
you know,
protect the tourists during the World Cup and Olympics so that violence has just
come right back to the fellas
say again.
There's just so much shit to pay attention to.
Yeah.
And Rio,
the image Rio is still,
you know,
sand bar on the beach and I've been a few times,
right?
Yeah.
I've been for UFC events,
it's beautiful people.
Very nice,
very friendly.
But then you go two or three miles up into the hills,
it's another world while we drove,
when you land at the airport,
you drive through the favelas on the way to Rio and you're like,
Whoa,
this is a,
this is a different kind of poverty.
And during the World Cup and Olympics,
they put billboards next to that road to block the view of the favelas.
Did they rely on those billboards are now starting to fall apart and you can now
see and see it again.
Yeah.
Wow.
And you can hear it if you,
if you stay close to their,
you'll hear.
I mean,
we went into the favelas many times.
We saw one guy who was suspected of being a police informer.
Um,
so the,
the trafficking gangs had captured him slash her his leg.
So he was laying on the ground,
put four rifle to his head and just unloaded.
And his chin was still kind of where it should be.
But everything else was,
this is when you got there.
Well,
because there,
right afterwards,
sorry.
No,
we didn't witness it happening and we've got there right afterwards.
But yeah,
it's,
I mean,
hideous violence there on,
I'm on a massive scale.
And also I got into an argument with him the other day about this,
um,
deeply racist.
Uh,
you know,
the,
the rich be minima tend to be white,
European descendants.
The poor kids getting shot in the favelas,
uh,
almost all black.
And if you walk into a bar and Ipanema with a black girl,
everyone will assume she's a prostitute.
If you walk into a bar and if an email with a black guy,
everyone was humans,
a drug dealer.
Um,
and again,
the exact opposite of,
of the public image of sort of Brazil Ipanema is the more wealthy area because
there is,
yeah,
that's the very best as the very wealthy,
Nice Beach,
um,
area with all the Nice hotels and apartment blocks.
But they still must get robbed all the time down there.
Right.
It used to be that the violence was separated from the ready,
which areas,
but there are now a lot of wealthy Brazilians leaving because it's,
it's,
it's affecting everywhere now.
I mean,
the,
one of the experts we interviewed in the last film said,
um,
I believe it was one in three Rio residents will get caught in crossfire at some
point over the course of a year.
I might be wrong.
And I believe it was one in three.
Yeah.
But it was a massive,
massive number.
Yeah.
Fuck.
I mean if,
if you're anywhere near a favela,
you'll hear it.
Most Nigel head shots being fired most nights and not like bom,
Bom,
Bom.
You know,
you'll hear a fight going on to Jesus Christ.
How much time do you spend over there?
Uh,
three weeks I believe it was.
Wow.
And what are you covering?
Uh,
we did a film about the pacification campaign,
the police and army clearing the favelas before the World Cup Olympics.
So we went back just to see,
just to sort of illuminated for people to think that this is what Brazil's
actually lark and see what yeah,
what happened afterwards.
And those areas were abandoned as soon as the World Cup and Olympics were over.
Dude,
I don't know how you do this.
You're so friendly too.
Like he's so easy going live here.
He seems so peaceful.
Like you don't seem like a shell shocked
guy,
you know,
you really don't.
You seem very,
very even.
Oh that's,
that's,
that's good to here.
Six months ago.
Yeah.
I mean,
I think I still have PTSD,
but it definitely helped.
And I bumped into a friend of mine,
the Diet Dan Reed,
who made the Michael Jackson documentary.
I saw him in New York a few weeks,
Neverland.
When you said,
Ben,
you just seem to just seem a bit a bit calmer.
What,
what is your take on that documentary?
I have not watched it,
but I've heard that those two guys at testified saying that nothing had ever
happened to them before this and then,
then now they're down on their luck and now they've changed their tune and
saying that it was,
they,
they go into that in detail in the dark and uh,
basically there'd been replaced by the new young boy to the side.
And then Michael reached out and said,
I need you to help me.
And they say it was exciting,
the idea to be,
to be back in Michael's good books and be wanted by Michael again until they,
they,
they talk about that very openly.
I had done it with them a week before the film came out and I believe them
really?
Yeah.
And,
and one of them certainly I think has,
has what looks like the symptoms of Ptsd.
And the other one I think went through therapy before he was able to talk about
this stuff.
So I don't think they're doing it for,
for financial gain.
But what did you think about the Dr. Michael Jackson's doctor saying that he was
chemically castrated?
Oh,
I didn't,
I didn't hear that.
Who knew that this was something that we've talked about before because his
voice was so different.
And to me,
I said a long time ago before his doctor came out and said he was coming
castrate,
I said,
these sounds are Castrato.
He sounds like one of those men who are taking his boys and you know,
the 1,870 he chose to do it.
The doctor saying,
I don't know.
I think the doctor saying that his father did it to them.
I think that was with,
this is the doctor that killed him mother.
So take that with a grain of salt.
Right.
But they were saying that he chemically crashed,
treated him to preserve his voice.
Which,
you know,
it sounds preposterous until you look at this frame.
I mean,
it did not have the frame of a person who takes the kids to run because he was
the same kids who did not have those kids.
And now he's getting,
not as kids,
but definitely not as kids.
I mean,
it's what we're talking to her about how it's easy to get the facts to fit a
theory.
Right.
But those kids are not his kids.
Those are the whitest kids you're ever going to look at.
They're really white.
I mean,
they're not part African American.
and he,
we got to remember before his Videle Lygo kicked in.
He was very dark.
You know,
he looked like his brothers.
Yeah.
It looked like his father.
I mean it's,
um,
I dunno,
I hadn't heard that theory before that his kids,
his kids getting his kids.
Really,
I haven't had many theories.
I'm not,
I don't think that much about Michael Jackson.
So I mean,
I think that's just been pretty much established.
Yeah.
That his kids weren't really as kids.
And I think is the woman that he had children with.
I think it was all on the record saying they never had sex.
Like I think,
yeah,
I think they,
I think they talk about that as well.
Yeah.
I Dunno,
but it's it,
when we had a similar case in the UK with Jimmy Savile,
like the most popular,
that's,
that seems even worse.
And the documentary is great because it's a portrait
of how you grew them,
not just the kid,
but the family as well.
And in some ways you grew me entire country to the point where if accusations
come out,
everyone says,
no,
not him.
No Way.
That's,
that's how it works.
Or he looked like a monster and Michael Jackson looked like a monster
eventually.
But when we always go back to him as a boy when he was singing an ABC,
I mean he was this adorable little kid,
incredibly talented and so dynamic and exciting to watch.
Like God,
he's so talented.
Look at him.
And then in thriller,
I mean everybody loved him.
But Jimmy Savile,
it looks like a monster in retrospect.
I wrote to him as a kid because he had the show called Jim,
we'll fix it.
Right.
We had grant you your wish and then you'd sit on his lap and he'd give you a
medal.
You got off light.
No one thought he was a monster back then.
No one.
But he was so hideous.
Yeah.
And,
and uh,
Louis through did a great documentary with him.
When he says he keeps his mother's bedroom exactly what it was and all the
clothes hanging in there.
Yeah.
But honestly,
in his lifetime this was not discussed.
Yeah.
And like I say,
I think he groomed the entire country.
Well,
there's so many cases like that where you have this systemic pedophile situation
that doesn't make sense.
Like,
how did this,
how did this last,
like Penn state,
like the Sandusky case,
like how did this,
how did,
everyone seems to have known about it.
How did it last?
And people had seen a kid in the shower and hadn't,
I mean,
yeah,
you think now you'd,
you'd,
you'd kill yourself if you didn't intervene in some way.
I think it's also easy to forget how much that wasn't part of the conversation
back then though.
You know the idea that there are pdf files out there and it's,
it's actually incredibly widespread.
That just wasn't right.
That wasn't something people were worried about back then from my memory,
at least.
Anyway,
no,
it was church who was Catholic Church priests.
We knew about that ever other than that,
but there was no discussion of like some world famous football coach who was
secretly fucking kids like that.
You never heard that.
I mean,
and paternal they think had to have known.
There's no way he couldn't have known or at least been exposed to some of it
and,
and to the conversation we had earlier,
I remember that,
that great documentary where I guide protest in front of the statue and another
guy comes up and tries to beat him up just for daring to suggest that,
you know,
this,
this hero of his would be capable of that.
People just,
you know,
they just can't fathom it because they've been so well groomed and was also Penn
state.
Football is just sucks.
It's a religion.
It's so important to them it's,
and to,
to see that these people that were in charge of it,
we're so fucked up.
Yeah.
Jesus man's shows a bummer.
Sorry about that.
But you know,
do you plan on doing this Mtma therapy on a regular basis and what,
what sort of an impact do you think?
I mean when,
when you go over the results of the first therapy where you are almost
immediately alleviates,
you have a lot of your feelings,
but you still are thinking about planning your next adventure
and your,
your,
your next project.
Um,
I'm probably gonna do a full session.
The therapist recommended a full session,
which isn't what they normally do.
But that said,
I mean,
I thought,
I thought being able to cry would be a major breakthrough and that's part of
this therapy.
Um,
and that's,
you do,
you normally can't cry at all.
I haven't cried since I was 13 years old or something.
14 years old.
Well that's different because that predates your war correspondents.
Yeah.
I mean English culture,
it's,
you know,
my grandparents fought in the war were tough as nails.
It's,
you know,
there is this pressure to be,
to be tough.
And the first normal therapy session,
I told her what I thought was quite an everyday story about an experience in war
to the therapist.
And he cried.
Oh,
Jesus.
And then the first Mbma session,
the therapist cried,
I don't know,
two or three times and the camera man cried and I still was still couldn't get
there.
And then the third session I need,
he did.
And I like,
my jaw was trembling and I kind of thought,
oh,
there's,
there's going to be this.
What would it felt like?
A breakthrough and still having camp.
What were,
what were they crying about?
Uh,
I can't even remember what stories you just had to show has been a bummer.
Like the stories,
I just tell him that,
you know,
well,
I mean I'm,
I'm joking kind of job.
This is what happened.
You're talking about it.
This is one of the,
you know,
one of the lesser symptoms of doing this is you,
you turn up to a party or a dinner or something,
you know,
with people that are enjoying the sell theirselves,
a smiling say,
oh,
this is Ben.
Ben just come back from,
from Yemen.
I,
what's it like in Yemen,
Ben?
You really,
really want to know.
Yeah,
tell us.
And then 10 minutes later there's this dark cloud of the evening and it was just
like Jesus.
So you just feel like you're,
you know,
you're just killing,
killing the cutting and the new state.
Can you talk,
Yay.
I've got bad habit of doing that by,
I can't even remember what the stories were that the ad that effect,
what does it like when you go to dinner with fellow war journalists?
Um,
what do you guys talk about?
I'm not,
there's a few that were really good friends and we can talk about all this
stuff.
There's a lot of that.
I'm not,
I'm not that close to and I don't likely,
you know,
the,
the mutual,
you know,
backpacking that goes on with it.
And was that what it is?
I kind of think,
you know,
if you're doing this for a living,
like you,
you,
you shouldn't be sharing stories with other people who cover that country.
Other,
the other people from,
you know,
from your background,
from your country,
you should be talking to the people from that country.
And a lot of journalists,
I mean,
it's possible in Afghanistan,
in Syria,
in Iraq,
to have a pretty good life.
You stay in the five star hotel,
you eat well,
drink wine every night and you,
you know,
you,
you get information from each other.
Right.
And I think that defeats the point of,
of foreign reporting.
Oh,
I see.
So consciously or unconsciously,
I,
I'm not,
you know,
I don't spend a lot of time with,
with other watch enlists there,
there were those who I deeply admire who I see every now and again,
like Sebastian younger.
Um,
but I'm not,
I don't,
I don't hang out with them day in,
day out.
So there's levels to the involvement.
Yeah.
To,
whether,
how deeply you're immersed and it's,
it's,
it's completely upside down in the state because the TV,
new Gen TV news journalists aren't deeply involved and just want to get that
quick shot of them looking like they're somewhere Middle East and he closest to
the front line with the flak jacket on the perfectly ironed shirt and they're
not,
they're not sweating or even worse.
The Brian Williams type situation.
Yeah,
yeah.
Or on the roof of the five star hotel.
Sometimes you might see people report about what's happening with Isis and
they're in Beirut.
Right.
And I think they're relying on the fact that a lot of people don't understand
that it's a different country.
Um,
but you know,
those guys,
some of those guys are paid millions and treated very,
very well.
The photographers and print journalists who are immersed and I spending weeks
there sometimes struggling to make a living and aren't well known and aren't
well supported.
What is it about the talking head in front of the camera that we want so badly?
I mean,
I think it's,
it's,
it's a way for the news networks to,
to claim credibility and then when you see them get deployed,
they're not focused on getting material from the war in these countries.
They're focused on the,
on the two way right now talking Shar guy from wherever.
Right.
That's more important than actually spending days collecting footage of what's
actually going on.
It seems like you see that rarely if ever these days it's more and more rare.
It,
it,
it seemed to me that during like Desert Storm,
um,
in the 90s,
there was always someone that was over there and it seemed like there was real
threat and it was really going on.
But now everything seems to be done from the desk and you don't really see a lot
of,
I mean,
am I right about that?
Yeah.
I mean,
I think in most of the,
a lot of the major news networks said to their crews,
you're not allowed to spend the night in Mosul.
You know,
you can go there and film a street and to be some refugees who just escaped isis
territory,
but you can't spend days on end there.
Whereas the freelance photographers and some of the writers,
they were spending days on end there and getting,
getting the real stuff.
Is it because the on camera people will be targeted?
Um,
I just think the risk is too high,
full stop for the entire crew.
And certainly if you know,
when a story is really big and you send one of the very well known
correspondence there,
then yeah,
they can't be running around,
um,
you know,
filming house to house fighting.
So when you're over there and you see these guys show up and you know that
they're just going to be hanging out with the hotel and what does that feel in
like,
uh,
yeah,
I mean,
I'm pretty disdainful of those.
Yeah.
Those guys you have to be,
yeah.
Yeah.
It's funny you see these films like,
um,
whiskey,
tango,
Foxtrot about Afghanistan and I just,
yeah,
I just don't recognize that,
that world that,
you know,
partying every night,
whatever bar or restaurant.
I just,
I just think if you're there and you're obviously in the wrong place,
right,
right.
And it's not,
it's not an adventure,
you know,
it's not a fun trip for you of,
of wild times and you know,
it,
it shouldn't be that.
It should be,
um,
I mean from,
it feels like an endurance test every time you go.
It should be hard and you should be spending time with the people you're
covering.
And you know,
sometimes you can,
you can think you've finished with someone and just go for dinner or tea.
And just by having normal human conversations,
you find out so much other stuff that you didn't code that to report.
And yeah,
that's,
that's what you have to be doing.
And that takes weeks,
weeks of getting closer to them and gain their trust.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And just,
just,
you know,
spending enough time there where you,
you then end up being in the right place at the right time to show something
really happening.
I mean,
in Mosul,
we filmed a,
the Iraqi army attacking a house where Isis,
we're shooting from the house and there were three or four families in the
house.
Um,
so the Iraqi army shot at Isis or the isis guys went down and encourage the
families to run towards us.
And just seeing that moment of civilians fleeing and escaping isis for the first
time after three years.
And when they turned the corner and tore us,
they knew that made it and they just collapsed to the ground.
They were kissing the ground,
they were hugging each other.
Now those are the moments you,
you,
you're,
you're trying to capture,
I mean,
I've never seen relief like Jesus Christ.
And how do they get them out of there?
What do they do from that stage?
Uh,
I mean,
they'll eventually walk out of Mosul itself and then there are people that can
take them to the,
the IDP camps around there and what,
we'll get them though,
you know,
the basic services they need and,
and medical services,
but there's not,
there's not much of that there.
And that that was the shocking in Yemen was the places that the Saudis numerati
said,
we're being so well supplied with food and water and tents and medical
facilities just,
just weren't at all.
We took no position.
We talked about Syria early,
you know,
half the population,
Brad's displaced.
Uh,
you know,
you're talking about,
12,
13 million people internally displaced or fled,
uh,
you know,
just unimaginable,
unimaginable.
And it's one of the biggest controversies in this country in terms of what to do
when the refugees come.
What,
what,
what do you do?
Some countries are taking them in with open arms.
Some countries are not.
And there's a lot of people that are concentrating on the negative aspects of
taking these people in new communicate community.
Um,
what,
what is your,
what is your take on watching all this thing happen?
Why watching all this?
I was,
I spent a Friday and Saturday in,
I'm in Houston with a group of Afghan interpreters who had been with in
Afghanistan who got the special immigrant visas and came to America with their,
with their families.
Um,
I cannot think of a better group of people who are contributing to,
to life here.
I mean,
on the Saturday morning they were,
they were running a food bank.
Um,
they've got jobs,
they're paying taxes.
Um,
yeah,
I mean I think we should welcome them with open arms.
And I think,
you know,
despite our moral obligation to do that,
I think we would benefit from,
from,
from doing it.
And you know,
we turned away Jewish refugees during World War II.
You'd think we'd learned from that and say never again.
You know,
um,
if you're,
if you're an American Christian,
I think Christianity is fairly clear and what to do with refugees.
Yes.
You know?
Um,
so,
so the Viton to,
to not only say no to refugees,
but also to vilify them and say,
oh look,
a lot of them are fighting age males.
Yeah.
Clearly Isis sneaking in.
I mean,
that's a level of,
of viciousness and ignorance that I just,
I just can't fathom the ignorance is,
it's,
it's very pervasive,
right?
It's like,
it's one of these things where we don't eat.
You don't know.
You're,
you're reading these stories and there is,
people were telling you these are fighting age males and that we could very well
be letting isis in to our country.
We were very well could be letting in these terrorist cells and allowing them to
come in.
But we also could be letting families in that this is a country that's made of
immigrants.
I mean it's one of the weirdest things in this country that this is a country
so,
so obsessed with borders and immigration,
but yet it's comprised entirely of immigrants.
Yeah,
there's a great,
um,
do you know,
Gary Young,
the purchase less?
No.
Uh,
he interviews Richard Spencer,
uh,
um,
and Richard spent,
Gary Young I think makes it a very similar point and which had spent a says
yeah,
but this country was built by white people.
Um,
you know,
um,
w we,
we came up with the,
no,
no it was,
it was literally built by black people carry young says,
he says,
yeah,
but only because we told them how to do it and it's on camera.
Gary Young says,
you know what,
I came to see you cause I thought you were the intellectual argument for,
for supporting Trump.
So I thought I'd might love Richard Spencer was the heat election.
Why did he think that?
I don't know.
But he says you're not.
This is just ridiculous.
And he just shuts down the interview,
turns around and walks off.
Well,
good for him.
I don't know anything about Richard Spencer other than he always gets mentioned
as a white supremacists.
I literally don't know what he stands for,
what he does or what he says,
and they will say he's well dressed and with a nice haircut.
This is a,
yeah,
it's just such a crazy subject.
The idea of,
I mean it would be nice if the whole world was up to the same standards of
health and
prosperity and he didn't have to worry about where you could go if the whole
world was essentially like the United States where you could go to where the
good parts were.
You know,
like if you live in Detroit and you save up your money,
you can move to Florida or wherever you want to go.
I mean,
you can do that.
This is the beautiful thing about living inside of a country.
Be fantastic.
If the whole world was like that,
if you could just kind of go wherever you would prosper and wherever things it'd
be.
Well,
but this,
the thing about refugees and other countries where we don't understand their
language or their culture and then you get scared because you hear that they're
Muslims were worried about Muslim terrorists and
it's again,
it's one more piece of information that just,
it just overwhelms you.
One more.
One more thing to concentrate on is the difference with the Muslims in the
Catholic Church and child abuse scandal.
Did a lot of people say,
oh,
therefore all Christians are suspicious and all Christian,
the secretly Peter filed,
right.
They're just not telling them no,
they didn't.
They didn't.
But they deal with,
with Muslims.
Well,
it's fear of the unknown.
You know,
it's a lot of it.
The languages and the,
the fact that we're,
you know,
there's also this,
there has to be this feeling that we've invaded their country,
several countries and been there for a long time.
And there's a deep seated resentment that,
you know,
there's the,
the thought of every time you accidentally blow up a wedding party with a drone,
every time you kill civilians,
every,
any times,
any collateral damage,
you are creating untold numbers of people that hate the United States.
You would think that I,
you know,
having traveled to much of this countries,
I don't see,
don't see that.
And yesterday I was interviewing the Afghan interpreters and I said,
what do you think about negotiating with the Taliban?
I mean,
in one case,
a good friend of mine called [inaudible],
um,
who's,
who's now living in,
in Houston.
I said,
um,
you know,
these guys killed your brother because you were working for the Americans and
interpreter.
So how do you feel about the Americans now doing a deal with the Taliban?
And what about if the u s leaves and the Taliban finishes off the government and
then comes after your family?
He said,
you know what,
America's not going to let that happen.
America has so much power and those what to do that they will make sure that any
agreement they reached with the Taliban will be enforceable and it will be safe.
He had so much faith in me,
far more than me.
Wow.
And that's,
that's what I hear far more often than,
than the opposite is it,
does that really depend on where you go?
I mean,
cause if you go certain places,
people have a lot of faith in Trump,
you know,
like Donald Trump's going to protect us from evil.
There's,
there's places where you go that,
I mean,
it's become a cliche,
but,
but I do think you'll,
you'll find a lot of places critical of American foreign policy.
That doesn't mean they're critical of America.
How do they parse that out?
Um,
I think,
I mean,
Vietnam I think is a good example.
You know,
we,
we have defeated communism or communism has been defeated in Vietnam just
because the new generation grow up and think western culture,
communism.
I know which one I want.
It's a simple choice.
Um,
and I think that young generation is,
is making that very simple choice and it could just mean democracy.
And you think that is in Afghanistan as well.
Yeah.
That they're recognizing that western culture provides more freedom and more
economic opportunity,
more prosperity.
Yeah.
Um,
and I haven't heard,
apart from from the Taliban,
I haven't heard much anti American feeling in Afghanistan at all really.
And also a lot of that,
I mean,
maybe I'm biased because a lot of the people I'm talking to add interactions
with,
with Americans.
Um,
but they would even say as many mistakes were made in the prosecuting of the war
with air strikes and nitrates and all that,
the American soldiers and Marines we met,
we knew were good people.
Um,
and,
and like I said,
with,
with Roche,
my interpreter,
it's,
it's incredible how many people still believe that to this day.
Um,
there are conspiracy theories.
So for example,
in Iraq,
you'll hear a lot of people say,
well,
Isis must have been part of America's plan.
And competence cannot explain what happened in Iraq.
This cannot be a mistake.
A lot of people believe that.
A lot of people believe that over here as well.
Right?
Yeah.
But that still doesn't mean they'll hate all Americans and America.
Um,
and it means a lot of them would love to visit and maybe even come and live
here.
Is that anything that you take seriously though,
those conspiracy theories?
Is there any validity to any of that stuff?
The massive failures in Iraq and Afghanistan have done massive damage to the u s
on the world stage.
There's no way the u s benefits from,
from what's what's happened.
I mean,
you know,
the Taliban would have done a deal in 2002 where they got almost nothing 18
years later,
$1 trillion later,
tens of thousands of lives later.
We're now negotiating with the Taliban where they might get a very good deal.
That's a massive humiliation for the u s and also Iran,
Russia,
his below others know that the u s is not going to intervene and lots of
countries,
so they're doing whatever they want and almost gloating about it,
knowing full well that America just doesn't,
it has this have the public support to intervene anywhere else for a very long
time.
What's the predominant conspiracy theory that they want to prolong this war
because of the military industrial complex because they're ma spending tons of
money and yeah,
gaining contracts and oil obviously in Iraq.
How many cars?
I as,
as I said to me,
do you think America failed in Afghanistan?
And I said,
of course I'd do it.
Like every film of maids like explains exactly how.
And he says,
no,
I think,
I think this is exactly what they want.
They want us being attacked on all sides by extremists.
So we will bow to their,
to their every wish.
And what do you say to that?
Um,
I mean,
you know,
he's,
he's met far more senior people than me,
so it's harder to argue with him.
But yeah,
I don't give that theory any,
any thought whatsoever.
That's the creepiest thought whatsoever,
is that the government wants these perpetual wars.
I mean,
that is the scariest conspiracy theory.
I'm not saying I support it,
but if you wanted to consider a conspiracy theory,
that's truly terrifying.
It's that they keep perpetual wars going on so that they can profit.
And you know,
George Hw Bush,
Bill Clinton benefited from airstrikes.
You know,
there's a quick possible bump in terms of your approval ratings.
That's been proven many times.
Um,
but these wars,
Iraq and Afghanistan,
you know,
having gone so long yeah.
And resulted in an,
I think a humiliating defeat in both countries.
Um,
no one's benefiting from that.
Well,
there's a numbness that this country has towards them now.
It's been so many generations.
It's been so many years.
There's so many.
I mean,
what,
what are the numbers of troops that have gone over to Afghanistan and Iraq and
come back?
It's just and not come back to there's this staggering and those towns,
they fought for Fallujah in Iraq,
Helmand province in Afghanistan,
and now back in the hands of the Taliban in Helmand province.
That's not even news here.
No.
All those places margin that the place I described earlier is now back in the
hands of the Taliban.
I've been,
um,
you know,
since I went there with the US marines,
I don't remember seeing a headline about them.
No,
no.
It's conveniently ignored because the public are just,
you know,
I've had long,
I've seen people come back in body bags or without leg and thinking,
I don't even know what victory looks like now.
I don't even know what the point of this is,
is anymore.
Yeah.
Where are we 16 years in?
Is that what it is now?
Afghanistan is 1818 yeah.
I mean,
they say the longest war in American history,
the first four or five years,
we went to Iraq very quickly and weren't doing very much in Afghanistan.
So,
you know,
I'd argue it's not an 1819 year war,
but it's,
it's a very long and very costly war.
Does this ever give you this feeling of hopelessness to like deal?
Do you look at yourself 40 years down the line still doing this?
Like how do,
how do you,
how do you approach this?
I think about that and I also think about just selling everything I have and
getting a little house in Jamaica and just
kind of think I tried to do my bit,
I'm not sure how much of a bit I did,
but,
but yeah,
like it's,
yeah,
it's,
it's a,
you can get that feeling very easily.
Yeah,
I would imagine that you,
you see so much and you see so much anguish in so much pain and suffering and
death and war and so much of it seems pointless that after a while you might
want to just detach,
disconnect.
And you said it earlier,
you know,
when you read the numbers here,
the stories,
I just,
I can't even take it seriously anymore.
I mean,
I can take it seriously,
but I can't fathom it,
you know?
I can't really take it onboard and really imagine what that's like.
Yeah.
And I've seen it with my own eyes.
And even then it's,
it's,
it's so hard to process.
Do you have an exit strategy?
No.
Um,
I mean I could make documentaries about other things,
um,
but I just don't think it would be this,
this,
this feels urgent to me.
Yeah.
You know?
Um,
and I question how useful this work is,
but it feels somewhat useful.
It certainly feels like the most useful thing I can do for now.
I'm not a doctor.
I'm not,
you know,
I'm not a politician.
So even if it's not that much use,
it's somewhat useful.
Well,
there's also the problem that you've,
you've dedicated so much of your time too.
I do think it's very useful.
You've dedicated so much time doing this that if you were to make a documentary
on something frivolous,
so this guy is a cabinet maker.
How do you do it,
Bob?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You might lose your fucking mind.
I mean,
I don't think once you've experienced what you've experienced,
it's probably very,
very difficult to look at the I the world through a normal lens and be satisfied
with normal results.
And it would be easy to dismiss anything else you did as being frivolous in
comparison to covering Yemen or Afghanistan or Congo or wherever.
So do you essentially just take it project by project and just keep going?
Yeah,
I mean,
I'm,
I'm thinking about this everyday right now because like I said in the,
in that first Mtma I thought this is what you want to do.
This is,
this is what you care about,
this is where your eyes.
Um,
so I'm,
I'm,
I'm pretty sure I want to,
I want to keep on doing it,
just maybe doing it in a different way.
I'm also really tempted just to try and take three months off and go to Costa
Rico and surf and do yoga and read books and just,
just,
just then see how I feel.
One of my favorite quotes is,
um,
is Nietzsche says a credit,
no thought,
not had in the open air while walking in,
in beautiful landscapes.
Uh,
what a great question.
Yeah.
Only when you're in that state of mind,
can you make the right decision?
So it'd be nice to make the decision in a place like that.
Sure.
It's mostly,
you mean you caught up in the momentum of these chaotic events and everyday
something new is happening that you want to be in.
I mean,
Isis are about to get defeated in Syria.
I want to be there to see it.
Yeah.
Cover it.
Do you think you really could take three months and go to Costa Rico?
Have you done that before?
I did nine days in Jamaica recently and nine whole days.
Yeah.
What was it like on Day two?
I loved every minute of it and I actually felt like my brain kind of woke up.
Yeah.
I just felt
the numbness I talked about earlier.
The worst thing is it just kills your curiosity.
Yeah.
And that's,
that's horrible.
Um,
and it just,
I just felt,
you know,
curious again,
I felt like my mind and I read a couple of books that weren't war related and I,
I focused on them.
I took it here and I,
you know,
I was,
I was in it for the experience and I loved it.
Why don't you just do that then take those three months
in different view.
You know,
I feel guilty.
You have do feel guilty.
Yeah.
That's what I was going to ask you.
I wanted to know if you felt guilty around day two.
I did.
I didn't,
I didn't feel guilty on this one cause it was,
it was quick.
Um,
I mean in the past,
you know,
you can,
you can go to a big fight and enjoy it and love it and you can go for a big
dinner and enjoy it and love it.
But that's about it.
Um,
you know,
a month of,
of luxury somewhere I think I would,
I would get uncomfortable.
You're not covering this fight when you went to the Earl sprints.
You know,
I've just,
I've made a couple of boxing docs.
I made a documentary about Danny Jacobs.
Did you realize when he survived cancer and the night he became a world
champion?
Oh,
why we were there.
And it was actually,
it was great to be able to say to people,
here's my latest film.
It'll make you feel really good.
So it to contradict what I said earlier,
that felt really good to be able to do that.
Maybe there's more of those in your future.
Yeah.
Um,
I was talking to someone the other day about maybe a documentary about the gym
that Danny comes from,
which is a door that leads to the basement of a Bodega in bedstuy and they don't
have three world champions.
Wow.
Assigning,
it's not a lot bigger than this room really.
It was a lower ceiling.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And it's underneath the Bodega.
Yeah.
It's a Sadam Ali,
you're think is the first Arab or Yemeni world champion.
He beat Miguel Kata.
Wow.
You got into boxing.
He's a kid.
So his daddy owns the Bodega,
built this gym in the basement and that's where he and Danny came up.
That's incredible.
And people walk past it.
And it's just this door.
There's no sign.
And then people don't even know.
Have you ever been to the Cronk team in Detroit?
No,
I haven't.
It's doesn't exist anymore,
does it?
No.
But you turn up to the building and you think this can't be the right place.
It's like a derelict building and you go down in this basement staircase into
the basement and there's this crappy gym and with one ring and a few bags and
that's it.
And then Tommy hands walks in and Henry,
I can one day walks in and you know,
Uber car walks in.
It's similar to that.
I had
Lennox Lewis on the podcast.
It was amazing.
He's amazing.
Yeah.
It seems like there's anything wrong with them at all.
I was wondering if chasses what's helping him,
you know,
because he doesn't seem to be sustaining any of the longterm and he got knocked
out a couple of times like that.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He really did.
You know?
I mean it's,
it's,
it's amazing.
I want,
I really do wonder,
because chess is so,
it's so difficult and your,
your mind is constantly firing.
And it and the brain in some ways does atrophy without use.
I mean,
whether it's not physical atrophy in terms of the size of it,
but it in terms of its abilities,
the more active you are solving.
Po George Foreman used to do a lot of crossword puzzles and things along those
lines and he actively sought different difficult little quizzes and puzzles and
things.
So he keep his mind sharp.
I met Quincy Jones a couple of months ago.
Oh yeah,
he's learning Mandarin,
I think.
How old is he?
I don't know.
He's in his eighties I think he just wanted to,
wow.
And by the way,
we had,
we had whole group of us had dinner and he was the last man to leave.
He closed the restaurant down.
Wow.
He's incredible.
I got into an argument about Rio and racism in Brazil,
in front of him really?
And he said that,
wait a minute,
I've been going to the favelas in Rio since the 60s I thought,
oh shit.
Here we go.
And he said,
and Ben's right,
Priscilla is deeply racist stuff.
I just got backed up by it by Quincy Jones.
Did an argument.
It was,
it was great,
but he's,
he says exactly the same thing.
Yeah.
So he does these things specifically to try to stay sharp.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Treat the brain like a muscle.
Yeah.
I think there's something to that.
I mean,
the [inaudible],
Lennox Lewis is obviously one anecdotal case,
but man,
he's so fucking sharp.
But that's what's so frightening about the numbness that comes from the PTSD is
if it takes away that curiosity,
it takes it out.
You've got a day off and you think,
I'm going to do a crossword.
I want to learn a language.
And it takes away that,
that energy that's,
that's terrifying,
right?
The numbness.
Yeah.
The,
the numbness that people,
well,
people in extreme poverty and extreme stress,
they,
they do experience that sort of numbness,
especially if you're in a dangerous neighborhood and just,
you're overwhelmed,
like you were saying about how the adrenaline eventually wears off and then,
you know,
just kind of,
you're in this weird gray state.
Yup.
And imagine someone,
someone in prison,
if you can awaken that,
you know,
um,
who knows what's possible.
But it seems like there's almost no effort at rehabilitation,
but awakening that is,
I don't think that difficult.
It just needs the right book or the right person,
the right film.
Well,
there's a place where I believe Mtma therapy could really have some amazing
results.
Yeah.
We've talked about it with,
with the therapist who were leading this.
I think that's their dream is to get in and do this in a prison because I
guarantee the majority of those guys in there as suffering from PTSD reaction or
reacting to it well,
and the majority of them probably been abused
and come from abusive environments and horrible situations,
and the,
the idea that we just hate people and lock them in cages and say,
well,
you've done your time now,
get get out,
and now you're going to be even more fucked up,
and now you're,
you know,
you're habituated.
Yeah.
You're used to being surrounded by violent criminals,
good luck in the world,
and we're going to make it even harder for you than anybody else to get a job or
an apartment.
Yeah.
I mean,
there was this story about Kim Kardashian and trying to pay this guy's rent
cause you've got out of jail and she's going to pay his rent for five years to
sort of get him on his feet.
He still can't get a fucking apartment.
Oh,
it had the first patent.
Nobody wants him.
No one wants to take him in.
Yeah.
It's,
and we don't ever want to give anybody a road to redemption.
You fuck up.
Once you do something wrong,
one robbery,
you get accused of fucking up.
Oh yeah.
And you'll have to write this for three years before we even stand trial.
Sure.
I read a stat the other day,
I think it's 94% of trials in the u s,
uh,
settled on a,
on a plea bargain.
Don't even go to trial.
And I thought that was wrong.
I thought that can't be accurate.
And while they scare people,
yeah.
Yeah.
You can plead,
plead guilty and get five years.
Yeah.
Well you can go to Charlotte and you'll probably get 30.
Which is insane.
Like,
what,
why would you give me five years if a judge would give me 30 like what is that?
What has happened in there if I am guilty?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No,
it's insane.
It's just like the,
the money saving sort of mechanism and,
and in ensuring that they don't lose,
you know,
and just they scare you.
Yeah.
You want to risk it all.
You want to 30 years you won't have a life,
but five years you will.
Yeah.
You might get out in to,
yeah,
be a good fella.
Don't stab anybody in jail.
Yeah.
What we do with people in this country when someone commits a crime is it's
pretty stunning.
And then when you factor in the fact that there's actual businesses that evolve
or revolve rather around profiting off of people being incarcerated is even
crazier.
Yep.
And no one investigates that either.
Yeah.
I mean,
again,
there are some great investigations,
Propublica,
people like that or how many people are reading them,
reading them.
That's a better way to say it.
Yeah.
It's not,
the new information is there.
And to your point about,
you know,
the,
the overflow of information,
it's all there.
It's just,
that's not the stuff at the top of the pile and nowhere near the top of the
pile.
That's probably the last thing that people concentrating on.
Cause you're assuming these people are bad criminals and you don't want them on
the street.
What do you want to do?
You want to feel,
think about all the good people out there that are struggling.
Concentrate of them first then what?
But this is part of what's wrong.
Part of what's wrong is these people were in these terrible situations,
terrible communities,
no way out,
nothing,
no positive image to model.
Everyone is a drug dealer or criminal.
It's crime around you all the time.
You wind up in the system,
he become incarcerated.
And then that's your life now.
Yeah.
And you're stuck in this thing and there's more of them in American prison than
anywhere else on the planet earth.
And as a foreigner here,
that's one of the things that just never
fails to shock me.
Well,
he,
England's got its own concerns too,
right?
I mean,
there's so many fucking stabbings in London now.
It's really crazy.
Yeah.
Uh,
yeah.
I mean,
but compared to shootings here,
this is nothing,
you know,
it's,
yeah.
But yeah,
it's,
it's definitely a problem.
And then you know,
that you just don't see police on the streets like he used to,
um,
in London and you don't see police.
My Dad was a policeman,
um,
before I was born.
But you,
you just don't see,
you know,
like streetwise policemen who were part of the local community,
getting intelligence,
knowing what's going on.
Um,
and often you'll see,
I mean,
I remember the riots in Brixton,
which we're right near where I lived and the police would stand back,
let the riot unfold and then just study video afterwards.
I recognize that guy will arrest him three days later.
Oh,
Jesus.
I didn't think that's what,
at least we're supposed to do while they want to protect their own house.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Ben,
how do we fix the world?
I have no idea.
I think it might be MGMA.
Actually,
I,
I know some people would,
would say that and make a good argument for it and uh,
and,
and really believe it,
it's just a really good argument for psychedelics remapping the world.
The really,
there's frivolous.
Yeah.
There's a moment in the Mtma documentary did,
were interview Rick Doblin,
you know,
the,
the mastermind of this.
Um,
I found him on,
oh wait,
yeah,
he's been on.
And at the end I say,
what's the potential of this if you get it legalized?
And he,
he basically says,
spiritual eyes,
the world world peace.
And I look at him like,
are you serious?
And he laughed and says,
I know it sounds crazy,
but I really believe this is possible.
It is possible.
What will not just Mgma,
MGMA is a great doorway because of its work with people with trauma,
but psilocybin as as well and you know,
suicide,
but obviously comes with these profound breakthrough psychedelic experiences
that complete,
not just completely remap your perceptions of life,
but show you a whole world that you didn't think could possibly exist.
And then all the other ones,
you know,
Ibogaine for all these people that are hooked on pills and it was one of the
most effective drugs or known molecules on earth and alleviating people.
Opiates.
I'm trying to ketamine now.
I've tried it a couple of times,
but that's what they want to try with me next.
Yeah.
I mean anything that makes people compassionate and kind to themselves as well
as to others.
Yes.
And it doesn't seem like that much of a jump.
I think most people have it in them.
Yeah.
You know,
not,
not that far under the surface.
People are scared,
they're scared and they're tense.
And you know,
people were just in constant states of conflict.
I mean,
that's a big thing that's going on in this world.
And one of the things that psychedelics do is they give you a brief break from
that conflict and then give you these thoughts that he probably would have never
achieved without these drugs.
And that's exactly what [inaudible] did with me.
It just removed all of those.
Are those fears?
Yeah.
Um,
yeah,
I think it's entirely possible.
I really do.
I think it's a real,
there's a,
there's a real case for us being able to set up some sort of clinics,
some sort of supervise
psychedelic experiences where one after another people start changing and they,
that trickles down.
They start changing the people around them.
People say,
well,
what happened to Mike?
Like,
Oh,
Mike did Mushrooms at this new clinic that they're opening up and the chain,
he's a new guy,
he's a different person.
He's so nice.
And then they joined two and I mean,
I just think there's so much room for that in this world.
It's so difficult to change who you are.
People rarely change.
They become a slightly different version of who they were five 10 15 years ago,
but they rarely actually change.
And then even to people who are completely skeptical about this,
the fact this is helping veterans,
everyone is behind it.
Well,
it's a great way to get in.
Yeah.
I mean,
they're very wise maps is in their approach to this one particular modality
because if they can actually achieve this,
you're going to also achieve it and help people that are in the,
they're in the community that's least likely to accept psychedelics,
right wing,
pro war,
you know,
mag a people like those,
those people.
I mean those are probably the least likely.
If you wanted to generalize,
to accept psychedelics.
Wait,
we watched the Fox News segment with Rick,
his house in Boston or Fox News,
talking about Mtma for veterans.
How did they approach it?
They looked at each other at the end and said,
do you ever think you'd do a pro ecstasy piece?
And they said,
no,
but if it helps the veterans,
I guess we're for it too,
right?
Yes,
exactly.
Yeah,
Yeah.
And if,
if it can lower crime rates to get people on mushrooms,
I mean,
if a dime methyl tryptamine can change people's perceptions,
there's so many of these different trucks too that you could introduce people to
under a clinical supervision setting where you could change that.
I mean,
how many people are involved in psychotherapy and it doesn't do a goddamn thing
to them.
They just keep going back and forth or they numb them up with pills.
Oh,
with me,
it was so off straight away.
They doubled the dose,
didn't work,
double the dose again.
I was just,
I was just a Zombie.
Yeah.
And that I don't have any experience with it,
but I know people that have had very negative experiences with the world becomes
all the bright colors are gone and the world just becomes a weird,
that's exact dollars.
Yeah.
Dealt,
dealt everything.
Yeah.
And the great thing about MDA is it's not a potential opioid crisis because it's
a therapist sitting down giving you the pill.
I don't give you 50 pills and you can abuse it however you want.
Yeah.
I was done.
I mean,
logistically doing what you say is going to be hard to set up and we didn't need
a lot of therapists,
a lot of facilities.
But it's,
it's,
it's possible.
Well,
once their success it,
and then it becomes a business,
then it can happen.
I mean,
once insurance starts covering it,
once people start experiencing positive benefits,
you can get it from both sides,
right.
You get it from the commerce aspect,
you get money starts coming in,
people start paying for it,
and it becomes a business that's successful.
It actually has good results.
People start talking,
well,
it or the people start opening up these,
these centers.
Yeah.
It,
there's so much potential to this and those people at maps and Rick Doblin and
all of his crew there,
they're really,
they have the real potential to change the world.
Yep.
And actually went the first session when I was really resisting it and fighting
it,
I just imagined Rick's face and the Met office faces in,
in,
uh,
South Carolina.
Um,
and just the kindness and benevolence.
Yeah.
And I just thought of those faces and that's what allowed me to just let it wash
over and wow.
And,
and hit me.
Um,
but Johnson and Johnson just got permission to use to,
to market their version of ketamine.
And right now,
uh,
the,
the dose of Ketamine I had was,
is like $90 a,
they're going to sell it for $15,000.
That's,
that's the danger of it getting properly legalized.
And as you said,
turned into a successful business.
Oh,
that's terrible.
Yeah.
Now why is it so expensive?
Just so they can make money off of it.
Now this is the therapeutic Joe dose of ketamine in a,
some sort of a psychiatric sort of survey.
What's the environment they're going to do it.
And
so they want to have it very much controlled,
but it looks like they want to stop there.
The therapist's giving it in the study,
um,
in their own office.
I mean,
which is,
which is what's going on now and have it controlled and under,
um,
you know,
the universe,
hospitals sort of situation and there is a very good,
um,
and it's not even underground cause I'm not sure even shorter.
It is not illegal here.
Right.
Cadamine yeah.
I think it is illegal now,
but there are therapists giving it out now.
And I,
I bought legally,
you know,
I think you can,
oh,
you bought it with the prescription real?
Yeah.
With the prescription in New York.
Oh,
maybe I'm wrong.
Is Ketamine legal.
Okay.
Legal under PR by prescription.
Maybe it's a schedule two drug or something along those lines.
I was going to get that.
Someone sent me the message about the $15,000 and what that fucking crazy ones.
Yeah.
90 to 15,000.
Which is far worse.
Far More than the,
the,
you know,
the amount that Martin Shkreli,
um,
put up the price
bright and went to jail for.
Yeah.
But uh,
yeah,
he's,
he's a Douche bag though.
It's easy to point at him.
You know he owns that Wu Tang clan album.
Yeah.
I had him with that.
I don't know.
Someone's got it,
man.
He's in jail.
Jail.
Yay.
So I studies,
I saw he's still running his business from like a burner cell phone in jail.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
Well,
what he's saying is though,
what happened to the Wu Tang clan album?
Uh,
I thought it was in possession of the FBI
or something.
Come on son.
That shit is hilarious.
That might be one of the most hilarious parts of that story.
The FBI owns the Wu Tang clan.
Forbid now album.
How much did he pay?
He pay like $1 million for it because it was up for auction.
I think this says he paid 2 million.
Wow.
You can never get that money back.
Especially if the track's got released.
But what a great marketing tool.
It's worth more than $2 million in the marketing.
And I feel so not released.
He confirmed he paid 2,000,040.
Yeah,
but he's pulled shit.
I bet he did though.
I mean,
if I had a gas,
you know,
I mean how many wealthy people out there?
Wu Tang fans?
A lot.
Yeah.
Probably probably a healthy bid.
Healthy bidding war as of uh,
this is as if like a year ago,
the feds have it.
So I don't know if there's an update on that heel.
There's always,
I mean,
when it's an individual that's like him,
that's easy to,
it's easy to look at him disparagingly.
Like,
look at this guy,
he's a Dick,
you know?
Oh,
he wants to raise the money or raise the price of these drugs that can help
people.
Fuck him.
Let's go get them.
But if it's Johnson and Johnson,
it's like,
yeah,
first they make maybe powder.
Yeah.
You know,
they're so respected.
It's such a common household name.
And then I'm calling it ketamine.
They're calling it s ketamine,
s ketamine.
Slightly different.
That sounds like a snail,
right?
It sounds like guess cargo and it's a nasal spray.
Oh,
Jesus.
I don't know how different that makes it,
but,
well,
it's better than shooting it up because I know that a lot of people take it
intramuscularly where you just jab it into your thigh,
I believe.
Yeah.
This is,
the drug will only be given by accredited specialists who must monitor patients
for two hours after administration.
I don't think you can just get it and go home and,
oh,
that makes sense.
Because a,
I know Neal Brennan did it and he had some very good results from it.
I talked,
I've spoke to him a few times.
He's tried everything.
He's a,
he's trying to,
he's great.
He's had a,
he's fucking hilarious guy.
He's had some real depression problems though.
He has some very good relief from magnetic therapy.
Yeah.
And if you seen the involuntary trembling thing,
he did as well.
No.
What's the video of that was,
is that I have no idea.
And involuntary tremoring just sitting there and like,
cause I am and showed her was just going,
but he,
they just shut,
it was great to sum up with something.
Nothing job test.
Just talking.
Oh,
so he just does it on purpose.
Yeah.
Oh,
this therapist and then it gets him to do it somehow and that helps him.
Yeah.
I,
you'd have to ask him.
I don't know the ins and outs.
I watched the three Mike's special thinking.
It was just another comedy stand up.
I had no idea about that,
that the,
that Mike being the serious stuff.
Yeah.
I thought it was incredible.
He's a brilliant guy.
He's very smart guy and his standup is outstanding and it just keeps getting
better.
But you know,
he's a guy fighting demons.
Yeah.
He's the classic case of the comedian that can never be happy unless he's on
stage killing,
you know,
and then,
even then that's brief.
Like he's just never this jovial,
funny guy.
But he's a brilliant comedian.
Yeah.
But as long as I've known him for many years,
he struggled.
And it sounds like he's kind of an unofficial executive producer for a bunch of
other comedians as well.
Um,
how,
so?
Like advising them and giving them notes and it seems like a whole bunch of
people,
I'm sure you guys going and get his input and people definitely respect him.
But
yeah,
I'm sure he gives people taglines and gives them advice and stuff like that.
He's very smart guy,
but to be as honest as he was and not even end it with a joke.
Right.
You know,
just the tail,
the serious story.
And then,
yeah,
that blew me away.
I met him on the Friday night and watched it on the Saturday morning and had no
idea.
And it was,
it was one of the best things I've seen for a long time.
Wow.
Yeah.
No,
he's a special guy.
It's uh,
it's hard when,
you know,
I've had a few friends take their life three in the last year.
Um,
and you know,
you,
you see a guy like Neil and you know,
he's constantly pursuing all these different therapies and constantly trying to
find something that alleviates this depression and you just keep hoping you keep
opening,
keep searching and keep hoping that one of these things sticks he's thinks
really see,
I mean,
he's very,
very proactive.
He's always searching for new things and is very open about it and talking about
it.
But the ketamine does seem to have helped him quite a bit.
And he was telling me like,
man,
he's like,
this is so fucking crazy.
I'm going to this doctor's office and having these full blown psychedelic
experiences at the doctor's office.
Yeah.
And then two hours later you're out on the street feeling completely normal.
What was your ketamine experience like?
Uh,
I took a tablet.
You put it under your tongue and let it dissolve for for 10 minutes.
And then I laid on a sofa in a therapist office for two hours when I was out on
the street again,
two hours later.
So how long did it take before kicked in?
I don't really know because I never thought it was kicking in.
Um,
but then I just found myself saying things and concluding things that I wouldn't
normally say.
And for the next week and a half I just felt like that was just a weight off.
Did you have any sort of a hallucinogenic experience?
None.
What's thing?
No hallucinating all,
listen to listen to music quite quietly.
But I,
you know,
I must go on for a few minutes here and there.
Sometimes it didn't talk at all.
Um,
but yeah,
just there was just this relief,
especially afterwards,
like in the,
in the week and a half or so off.
So it's just felt this,
just this lightness.
And you know,
to your point about Neil being so open to trying everything,
even that,
even taking that step is hard know sometimes even getting out the door.
Sure.
As hard,
let alone researching this stuff and trying everything.
I mean,
when I first moved to America,
I said,
okay,
you're not going to do yoga.
You're not going to do therapy.
You're not going to prescription drugs that's in New York.
Bullshit not to drop that.
Let's get to skepticism and to try everything.
You can be genuinely open to everything.
That's,
that's,
that's a lot in itself.
While it's hard for people to try anything new,
I mean,
you have to respect anytime anyone does anything new the first time.
But person straps on a pair of running shoes and goes for a jog,
it's fucking hard.
Yeah.
It's hard to just do something.
It's hard to change gears.
Yep.
And we'll be curious enough to try it in the first place.
You have to be open to the idea.
Not just be curious.
I mean,
in the case of taking something like ketamine brave,
you have to be brave.
I mean,
you're,
once you take,
you can't untake Aa,
you're on a ride.
Yeah.
They'd take the first MDA session was as frightened,
more frightening me than going to
Syria or Yemen or how so?
Um,
I guess the vulnerability,
I just thought I'd say things and accept things that,
that,
you know,
put up a front against for so long and it's a British thing.
I think it's very much a British thing,
but it's also in my identity has been a tough,
brave war correspondent.
Right.
And you can,
you can like that,
you know,
respected.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Um,
and yeah,
I dunno.
I Dunno.
When I had that feeling of relief in the last,
I think as the last,
no,
the first session,
sorry about all,
you could have a family and the dog and kids and enjoy it and be happy.
There's also a part of me that resisted that and thought,
no,
that's somehow taking your foot off the gas and somehow losing sight of what's
important and what your role is and what you can do to actually help things,
you know,
um,
and just,
you know,
doing whatever is good for you.
Okay.
It seems so conflicted because you obviously great,
get a great benefit out of this,
this ability to help you,
and you really do help.
And you really do put yourself in these incredibly difficult situations.
So there's,
there's something,
there's a,
there's a positive aspect of it,
but for sure there's a price of your pain that's pretty substantial.
Yeah.
And I,
before the MTMA therapy,
I thought,
if the price is on your own and you're not enjoying the things that most people
enjoy,
then that's the price you pay.
You know,
that's,
you know,
what you want to do and you'll do it,
whatever the price is.
Um,
and so I'm open the eyes to the idea of that,
that not being the case.
I hope that's the case.
I hope,
but not being the case.
That actually the case.
Yeah.
Wilson.
Ben.
Thank you,
man.
Thanks for coming in here and thanks for everything you do.
I really appreciate it.
It was great talking to you and,
uh,
I wish you well,
man.
If there's ever anything we can do,
please let me know.
Thank you.
Hm.